Hey. Whoa, hi. Hey, what are you doing? Are you busy right now? Because I'd love to do a podcast. Oh, that's what we're doing. Are you free? I think we're doing.
嘿。哇，嗨。嘿，你在干嘛？你现在忙吗？因为我很想录一期播客。哦，我们正在录呢。你有空吗？我想我们正在录。
Let's call Will really quick. I think it would be better with three. Ring. Will? Ring. Hello? You've reached the messaging of Will Arnett. Oh, damn it.
我们快点给威尔打个电话吧。我觉得三个人一起会更好。嘟。威尔？嘟。喂？你拨打的是威尔·阿奈特的语音信箱。哦，该死。
Oh, shoot. We missed him. Feel free to start an all-new Smartless. Oh, baby. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Feel free to start an all-new Smartless. Oh, baby!
哦，糟了。我们错过他了。随时可以开始一期全新的Smartless。哦，宝贝。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。Smart。随时可以开始一期全新的Smartless。哦，宝贝！
You know, I've been thinking about going, not changing, it's not really changing my name, but I'm thinking about just going with Just Will. Like kind of like share. Are the words Just Will, Just and Will? No, Will. Yeah, but Just Will would be clearer. Like more individual.
你知道，我一直在考虑，不是改名，也不是真的改名，但我考虑就叫“Just Will”。就像雪儿（Cher）那样。是“Just Will”这两个词，“Just”和“Will”吗？不，就叫“Will”。是啊，但“Just Will”会更清楚。更有个人特色。
It's too close to Just Jack from that show. I'm not familiar. Me neither. I don't know what the show, but. So nobody's got, nobody picked Will yet, just the word Will. So I'm just gonna go Will, like you know how like Brazilian soccer players just go with like Pepe
那和那部剧里的“Just Jack”太像了。我不熟悉。我也不熟。我不知道那是什么剧，但是。所以没人，没人选“Will”这个名字，就单单“Will”这个词。所以我打算就叫“Will”，就像你知道的，巴西足球运动员那样，只用像“贝贝”
or whatever on the back of their, so I just wanna do that. Don't say yeah, Sean, you don't know what the hell he's talking about. No I don't. But you know what took me forever to realize, you remember that? Oh hang on, can I have a crack at this? Because the list is long.
或者别的什么印在球衣背后，所以我只想那样做。别说“是啊，肖恩”，你根本不知道他在胡扯什么。不，我不知道。但你知道我花了多久才意识到吗，你还记得那个吗？哦等等，我能试着说一下吗？因为名单很长。
That the world might not be flat? No, that will, I, will, period, I, period, M, period, you know, the rapper, singer, guy, whatever. Will.i.am? Yeah, Will.i.am. Yeah, is William, you stupid bastard? I didn't realize that. You're kidding, you're kidding.
世界可能不是平的？不，是Will，I，Will，句号，I，句号，M，句号，你知道的，那个说唱歌手、歌手，什么的。Will.i.am？对，Will.i.am。对，那是William，你这个笨蛋？我没意识到这一点。你在开玩笑吧，你在开玩笑吧。
I swear to God, till like a year ago, I looked at it, I was like, oh, it's William. When you say you didn't realize that. You're kidding, you're kidding. I swear to God, until like a year ago, I looked at it, I was like, oh, it's William. When you say you didn't realize, how is that possible? Well, nothing's gonna beat Beatles, right? No, that beats Beatles to me. That was a big shock to know. Lots of people on my side, guys, lots of people on my side.
我发誓，直到大约一年前，我看着那个名字，我心想，哦，原来是William。当你说是你没意识到的时候。你在开玩笑吧，你在开玩笑吧。我发誓，直到大约一年前，我看着那个名字，我心想，哦，原来是William。当你说是你没意识到的时候，这怎么可能呢？好吧，没什么能比得过披头士乐队，对吧？不，对我来说那比披头士更震撼。知道这一点真是个大冲击。很多人站在我这边，伙计们，很多人站在我这边。
I think Will.i.am beats Beatles. Will, I like that the hair is still growing. You got a real Carol Brady kick out on the back. I love it. Are you gonna, what are we gonna do with it? Have you settled on what the look's gonna be for the big film? No, I mean, I think you're kinda looking at it.
我觉得Will.i.am比披头士更震撼。Will，我喜欢你头发还在长。你后脑勺留了个真正的卡罗尔·布雷迪式的发型。我喜欢。你打算，我们打算怎么处理它？你确定好大电影里的造型了吗？不，我是说，你现在看到的差不多就是了。
Am I looking at it, all right. Yeah, there's not a whole lot. Are you gonna put gel in it? You gonna put mousse? Well, it's gonna be all over the place and it's gonna be, you know. Yeah. This is gonna be what it is, man.
我看到的就是这样吗，好吧。对，没剩下多少了。你打算往上面抹发胶吗？你要用摩丝吗？嗯，它会乱糟糟的，而且会，你知道的。对。这就是它本来的样子，伙计。
You know, I'm kind of freewheeling. You know me. You're freewheeling. This sounds rad. Did you guys know anything about me? You're talking to Will, simply, just Will. Yeah, he's really easygoing and freewheeling. Freewheeling.
你知道，我有点随性。你了解我。你很随性。这听起来很棒。你们对我了解多少？你在和Will说话，简单来说，就是Will。对，他真的很随和，很随性。随性。
You know, Scotty and I, I said to Jay, we missed you last week, Will. I know, I know, how was it? It was fun, it was really small. There was some good laughs. It was plenty of oxygen for everyone with you not there. Wow. I think our audience will agree.
你知道，斯科蒂和我，我对杰伊说，我们上周想你了，Will。我知道，我知道，怎么样？很有趣，规模很小。笑声不断。你不在的时候，大家的氧气都很充足。哇。我想我们的听众会同意的。
No, we did, now you were still in town or you had just left Sunday? I left Sunday night, yeah, yeah. And now you're in New York and you're there for the hall, for the long haul. You're not gonna come back. I'm gonna come back in a couple weeks for a weekend. Yeah.
不，我们确实，你当时还在城里，还是刚在周日离开？我周日晚上离开的，对，对。现在你在纽约，而且是长期驻扎。你不会回来了。我几周后会回来过个周末。对。
Grab some toiletries? Grab a few misplaced items. Some sundries. And then, yeah, no, no, go back and see the kids and then they're gonna come out here. It's gonna be great. I see you got the Whisper booth all set up, don't you? Look at that. Yeah, I got it all set up.
拿点洗漱用品？拿几件落下的东西。一些杂物。然后，对，不，不，回去看看孩子们，然后他们会来这里。那会很棒。我看到你把Whisper录音棚都装好了，是吧？看那个。对，我全都装好了。
You're leaving soon. I'm leaving in three weeks, I think. Yeah, I gotta start doing some homework, God damn it. I've really been putting it off. I'm like that though. I just kick it all down the road, and then I cram. What, you mean memorizing lines and stuff? Well, just like rereading and rereading the scripts
你很快就要走了。我想我三周后走。对，我得开始做点功课了，该死。我真的拖了很久。不过我就是那样。我总是把事情往后推，然后临时抱佛脚。什么，你是说背台词之类的？嗯，就是反复阅读剧本
and like I gotta figure out my look. You know, I'm playing this St. Louis weatherman. I think you got it. I think you got it too. No, hey, don't be hurtful. You're default. No, I've got a... Tell us what it's like outside today.
还有我得确定我的造型。你知道，我要演那个圣路易斯的气象员。我想你搞定了。我想你也搞定了。不，嘿，别伤人。你是默认的。不，我有一个……告诉我们今天外面天气怎么样。
Like it's gonna be a mustache and maybe parting the hair, and some glasses, but I don't want to get too anchorman with it. Sure. Yeah, yeah, you don't want it to be a cartoonic caricature. You know, the other thing, JB, if you do happen to... Guys, that's my ride. If you do happen to... By the way, our guest is in Times Square. I'm so excited for this.
就像会留个小胡子，可能把头发中分，再戴副眼镜，但我不想让它看起来太像新闻主播。当然。对，对，你不想让它变成卡通式的漫画形象。你知道，还有件事，JB，如果你碰巧……伙计们，那是来接我的车。如果你碰巧……顺便说一句，我们的嘉宾在时代广场。我太兴奋了。
Um, just me. She's selling pretzels live. JB, I will say this and we can get your guest, but if you do go the parted, I'm excited if you go parted because it'll mean you're finally put like a comb or a brush in your hair. This is gonna be exciting for everybody. I might actually blow dry it too.
嗯，就我一个。她在现场卖椒盐卷饼。JB，我会说这个，我们可以请你的嘉宾进来，但如果你真的选了中分，我很兴奋，因为这意味着你终于要在头发上用梳子或刷子了。这对每个人来说都会很兴奋。我可能真的会用吹风机吹一下。
Wait, it looks so terrible. It's gonna be gigantic. It's gonna be like that. Wait, I wanna tell you, Willie, that I said to Jay on Sunday, we got a turntable, Scotty and I, for Christmas, you know? Did I tell you that already? Two turntables and a microphone.
等等，看起来太糟糕了。它会变得巨大。会像那样。等等，我想告诉你，Willie，我周日对杰伊说，斯科蒂和我，我们圣诞节买了个唱片机，你知道吗？我之前告诉过你吗？两台唱片机和一个麦克风。
No. Did I tell you, I got a stack of wax here that I'm just looking to put on somewhere, you know? No, seriously, it's so fun. We put it on at night and we just listen to like soundtracks or whatever. Like I haven't listened to vinyl since I was a kid. Can you just hold on a second?
没有。我告诉过你吗，我这儿有一堆黑胶唱片，我正想找个地方放呢，你知道吗？不，说真的，太有趣了。我们晚上放着听，就听听原声带什么的。我小时候之后就没听过黑胶了。你能等一下吗？
So even when you're on vinyl, you're listening to Star Wars? Yeah, a little bit. Fucking. And E.T. Even when you're on a record. The E.T. soundtrack. Jesus Christ. He's got a vinyl of the Star Trek and Star Wars soundtracks.
所以即使你在听黑胶，你也在听《星球大战》？对，一点点。该死。还有《E.T.》。即使你在听唱片。《E.T.》原声带。天哪。他有《星际迷航》和《星球大战》原声带的黑胶唱片。
Hey Sean, when TikTok went dark, did you and Scotty make your final promises to each other? Can you imagine Sean and Scotty putting on a record, putting the needle down the record and just dancing around the house there just like they don't care? They're not dancing, they're going like, this is the part, remember when Elliot gets on his bike and he puts him in the basket? Do a dance for that. Do a dance for that. Totally.
嘿肖恩，当TikTok下线时，你和斯科蒂有没有对彼此做出最后的承诺？你能想象肖恩和斯科蒂放上一张唱片，把唱针放下去，然后在屋子里跳舞，就像他们不在乎一样吗？他们不是在跳舞，他们是在说，这是这一段，还记得艾略特骑上自行车，把外星人放进篮子里的时候吗？为那个跳个舞吧。为那个跳个舞吧。完全是。
This is when he comes and he's in the closet and he puts his finger out and he says, he won't go home. Do you remember that? All right, today. And he's got the shaky hands, yeah. Today. Today.
这是当他过来，躲在壁橱里，伸出手指说，他不会回家的。你记得吗？好吧，今天。而且他的手在颤抖，对。今天。今天。
We've got a guest who's just starting to get a little momentum and show business. We're excited to have her here at the beginning. So far, she's off to a good start though with the singing stuff. She's sold over 90 million records. She's got 50 billion streams and she's got a couple of Grammys. What are you talking about?
我们请到了一位在演艺圈刚开始崭露头角的嘉宾。我们很高兴能在她起步阶段请到她。不过到目前为止，她在唱歌方面已经有了一个很好的开端。她已经卖出了超过9000万张唱片。她有500亿次流媒体播放量，还拿过几座格莱美奖。你在说什么？
Yeah, with the acting, latest film's just gone past 700 mil. She happens to be the seventh most followed person on Instagram with 376 million followers and she's got a cosmetic line and fragrance line that's earned just over a billion. So she's got a little bit of wind at her back now. She's stopping by for a little advice and encouragement from us geniuses before she officially gets out there
对，在演戏方面，最新的电影票房刚刚超过7亿。她恰好是Instagram上粉丝数第七多的人，拥有3.76亿粉丝，她还有一个化妆品系列和香水系列，收入刚刚超过10亿。所以她现在顺风顺水。她在正式大展拳脚之前，顺道来我们这些天才这里寻求一点建议和鼓励
and gives it a go. Please give an incredible hello to the incredible Ariana Grande Come on out! That was very silly Hi guys! Hi Ariana! Oh my gosh this is exciting
并尝试一下。请用难以置信的热情欢迎难以置信的爱莉安娜·格兰德。出来吧！那太傻了。嗨，伙计们！嗨，爱莉安娜！天哪，这太令人兴奋了。
I'm so happy to be here with you guys I know, I'm happy you said yes and you're here Wait where are you Ariana? New York? Big getch A.B. What did you do? What strings did you pull? It's a lot because you're a very expensive guest right here, guys, so use your time wisely. Stop. I love you all so much and I love the show so much.
我很高兴能和你们在一起。我知道，我很高兴你答应了，而且你来了。等等，你在哪，爱莉安娜？纽约？大牌嘉宾，A.B.。你做了什么？你动用了什么关系？这很不容易，因为你是一位非常昂贵的嘉宾，伙计们，所以要明智地利用时间。停。我非常爱你们所有人，我也非常喜欢这个节目。
I am so happy to be here. Oh, you've never heard it. You're very nice to say that. Even for a podcast, you look gorgeous. I mean, even just for showing up. Oh my God, thank you. Yeah, we could have been like this. You didn't have to.
我很高兴能来到这里。哦，你从来没听过。你这么说真是太好了。即使是对于播客来说，你也看起来美极了。我是说，仅仅是你能来。天哪，谢谢。对，我们本来可能会像这样。你没必要这么做。
Oh my God, that's so nice. How are you? How is everyone? How are you guys? Everyone is good. We're all really good. How are you is more to the point. My gosh, you got so much going on. How are you? I'm good. I'm currently in London and I just got here. So I'm just adjusting to the time.
天哪，那太好了。你好吗？大家都好吗？你们好吗？大家都很好。我们都非常好。你怎么样才是重点。天哪，你忙的事太多了。你好吗？我很好。我目前在伦敦，刚到这里。所以我正在调整时差。
Yeah, the jet lag's no good? No, it's like it's fine. You know, you get to a point where you're just kind of like, whatever, whatever needs to be will be. I feel like it's worse coming back, right? It's worse coming back to the States. No, no, from LA to London or anywhere in Europe is the worst on the planet, I think. And then coming back is really fun because then you're a morning person for a while. Yeah.
对，时差不好受吧？不，就像，没关系。你知道，你会达到一个点，就是觉得，随便吧，该怎么样就怎么样。我觉得回来的时候更糟，对吧？回到美国更糟。不，不，从洛杉矶到伦敦或欧洲任何地方，我认为是地球上最糟糕的。然后回来的时候真的很有趣，因为那样你有一段时间会变成早起的人。对。
Right, right, right. I love that. Did you just get in there today? Yeah, we just got here. So I'm excited. Right, right, right. I love that. Did you just get in there today? Yeah, we just got here. So I'm excited. Right. This is a great fun way to start the trip.
对，对，对。我喜欢这个。你今天刚到那里吗？对，我们刚到这里。所以我很兴奋。对。这是开始这段旅程的一种非常有趣的方式。
But let's start there. So like you're okay with the amount of things you take on and the way you fill your day. I mean, I guess I should put that in the form of a question. Are you okay with it? How much time do you sort of allocate to just hanging out? I mean, I feel really grateful for the balance that I have found.
但让我们从这里开始。所以，你对自己承担的事情的数量以及你填满一天的方式感到满意吗？我是说，我想我应该把它变成一个问题。你对此感到满意吗？你通常会分配多少时间来闲逛？我是说，我对自己找到的平衡感到非常感激。
I mean, this whole wicked journey has been quite different for me. And it's been obviously full steam ahead, but it's been so beautiful and so fun. I really feel like maybe when I was younger my head, but it's been so beautiful and so fun. Maybe when I was younger and it was during my first few years as a pop star, I really struggled with boundaries and not being able to say no when I needed to, because if I was running on empty.
我是说，整个《魔法坏女巫》的旅程对我来说非常不同。显然是一路全速前进，但它非常美丽，也非常有趣。我真的觉得也许当我年轻的时候，但它非常美丽，也非常有趣。也许当我年轻的时候，在我作为流行歌星的前几年，我真的在界限感上挣扎，当需要的时候无法说不，因为如果我精疲力竭的话。
But I really do feel like I've been able to find a balance and also a team who's really protective and amazing. And I love it. I really feel like I've thoroughly been able to enjoy this wicked insanity. I feel so present and grateful and that's been so beautiful. Well, Sean, you had a tough time with Boundaries
但我真的觉得我已经能够找到平衡，也找到了一个非常保护我且很棒的团队。我喜欢它。我真的觉得我已经彻底能够享受这种《魔法坏女巫》的疯狂了。我感到如此当下和感激，那真是太美好了。好吧，肖恩，你在界限感方面有过一段艰难的时期
when you first were introduced to Oreos. Like you. No. You did. I still do. I have to have them locked away. There's a lock on the door. There's a lock on the door.
当你第一次接触奥利奥的时候。像你一样。不。你有。我仍然有。我必须把它们锁起来。门上有把锁。门上有把锁。
Wait. So dumb. So dumb. So dumb. Oh, there's lots of dumb. Oh, wait a minute. What are we getting? Ariana, what if this was your press junket for the sequel to Wicked?
等等。太蠢了。太蠢了。太蠢了。哦，有很多蠢事。哦，等一下。我们要得到什么？爱莉安娜，如果这是你《魔法坏女巫》续集的媒体发布会呢？
Right now. You started now. I love it. Where does it end? Where does one end? You'd be like, why is it so low rent? Shut up! We love, by the way, we love Wicked.
现在。你现在开始了。我喜欢。它在哪里结束？哪里是一个终点？你会说，为什么这么低端？闭嘴！顺便说一句，我们喜欢《魔法坏女巫》。
We love the great Mark Platt. He's a friend, a long time friend. Love Mark and all the people involved with it. And you guys did an amazing job. Incredible. Tears, real tears in my eyes. And you've already shot the second one, right? Yes. Second one is done. We haven't seen it yet.
我们喜欢伟大的马克·普拉特。他是朋友，一位老朋友。爱马克和所有参与其中的人。你们做得太棒了。难以置信。泪水，我眼里真的有泪水。你们已经拍完第二部了，对吧？是的。第二部完成了。我们还没看过。
Really? Not done. Yeah. And it comes out maybe like this time next year? I have seen it. Yes, the same time next year, so November 22nd, but next year. I have seen it and it's not good. Ariana, you're barely even in it. All your stuff can be reshot. I don't want you to worry about it.
真的吗？没完成。对。它大概明年这个时候上映？我看过了。是的，明年这个时候，也就是11月22日，但那是明年。我看过了，它不好。爱莉安娜，你几乎没在里面。你所有的戏份都可以重拍。我不希望你担心。
Thank you for telling me. Thank you for having my back. So then you're set to start that junket in a few months. I mean, I suppose so. I think maybe there'll be a little bit of space in the summer. Let it breathe for a second, but it's very exciting. I mean, the response has just been so insanely
谢谢你告诉我。谢谢你支持我。所以你准备在几个月后开始那个发布会。我是说，我想是吧。我想夏天可能会有一点空档。让它喘口气，但这非常令人兴奋。我是说，反响简直太疯狂了
not what you expect or ever would anticipate ever. I know, could you imagine if it was just a big turd and you already, you had the second one already ready to go and you just knew you had like turn the interest. Well, that could still happen, God forbid, but you never know, I'm just kidding. I've done that, I'm sure we all have, right? We've gotta talk about something that just didn't work.
不是你预期的或会预料到的。我知道，你能想象如果它只是个大烂片，而你已经，你已经准备好第二部了，你只是知道你得……好吧，那仍然可能发生，上帝保佑，但你永远不知道，我只是开玩笑。我做过那种事，我相信我们都做过，对吧？我们得谈谈那些没成功的事情。
Wait, so Ariana, the last time I saw you was Hairspray Live. Yes. And we would share a trailer and you told me the funniest stories that I cannot repeat. We would giggle. Wait, wait, go back, go back.
等等，爱莉安娜，我上次见你是在《发胶星梦》直播版。是的。我们共用一个化妆车，你告诉我一些我不能重复的最有趣的故事。我们会咯咯笑。等等，等等，回去，回去。
The last time we saw each other, in Nancy, try not to slur your way through your words. Was where? Hairspray Live on NBC. Hairspray Live, okay. And you were sharing a single trailer or we were in a double banger? No, the hair and makeup. The hair and makeup. Oh, thank you. And you were sharing a single trailer or we were in a double banger? No, the hair and makeup.
我们上次见面，南希，试着别含糊不清地说话。是在哪？NBC的《发胶星梦》直播版。《发胶星梦》，好的。你们是共用一个单人化妆车，还是我们在双人车里？不，发型和化妆。发型和化妆。哦，谢谢。你们是共用一个单人化妆车，还是我们在双人车里？不，发型和化妆。
Hair and makeup. Oh, gotcha, okay. So we shared a chair. Very fun times. I didn't even know you used to do your hair and makeup. So talk a little bit about that. Oh my goodness. Were you just doing a blowout shot?
发型和化妆。哦，明白了，好的。所以我们共用一把椅子。非常有趣的时光。我甚至不知道你以前自己做发型和化妆。所以谈谈那个吧。哦，天哪。你当时只是在做吹风造型吗？
I didn't think she looked so good. Ariana, we did a weird talk show in the UK like 10 years ago. Do you remember that? At the same day? Wait, no. Uh-oh. What weird talk show did the UK like 10 years ago. Do you remember that? At the same day? Wait, no. Yeah. What weird talk show did we do?
我觉得她看起来没那么好。爱莉安娜，我们大约10年前在英国做过一个奇怪的脱口秀。你记得吗？在同一天？等等，没有。呃哦。什么奇怪的脱口秀在英国大约10年前。你记得吗？在同一天？等等，没有。对。我们做了什么奇怪的脱口秀？
It was called... Chatty Man? Yes! Yeah, with the drink cart. And like I think I rode the bicycle. Oh my God, that's right! It's back! Wait, I really leave an impression.
它叫……《Chatty Man》？对！对，有那个饮料车。而且我想我骑了自行车。哦，天哪，没错！它回来了！等等，我真的留下了深刻印象。
It's not you, it was the boundaries, remember? Maybe, was it bad bad? It was just me, I'm missing a couple of years. I'm super serious from that time. I'm missing a couple of years, I'm super serious from that time, I'm literally missing a few years. Well, so let me remind you, it was disgraceful, your behavior.
不是你，是界限感，记得吗？也许，是很糟糕吗？只是我，我错过了几年。我从那个时候起就超级认真。我错过了几年，我从那个时候起就超级认真，我真的错过了几年。好吧，让我提醒你，你的行为很丢人。
Oh no. No, no, no, no, no, no, you were great. Me? No, no, you were great. Okay, good. You were great, but what I wanted to, but we met at the time and you were, how old were you when you first released
哦，不。不，不，不，不，不，不，你很棒。我？不，不，你很棒。好的，很好。你很棒，但我想要的是，但我们在那个时候见面，你，你第一次发行的时候多大
your first record as a pop star? I think I was 19 when my first single off my first album came out, or 20. I was either 19 or 20. And had you been making music since you were a kid? She was in the musical 13 on Broadway. Yeah, I was a total theater nerd. I did Broadway first when I was 14.
你作为流行歌星的第一张唱片？我想我第一张专辑的第一首单曲出来时我19岁，或者20岁。我当时要么19岁要么20岁。你从孩子时就开始做音乐了吗？她在百老汇音乐剧《13》里。对，我是一个彻头彻尾的戏剧书呆子。我14岁时第一次演百老汇。
And then I was acting for a little bit. But I was always simultaneously writing songs and doing music. I just never expected it to kind of take over the way that it sort of did in a beautiful way. I just think that there was no way to kind of prepare for the way that it sort of did in like, you know, a beautiful way. I just think that there was no way to kind of prepare for that, especially, yeah. So you were a theater nerd and then you were like, oh, wait a second, the world wants me to be a pop star.
然后我演了一会儿戏。但我一直同时在写歌和做音乐。我只是没想到它会以那种美丽的方式接管我的生活。我只是觉得没有办法为那种方式做好准备，尤其是，对。所以你是个戏剧书呆子，然后你就像，哦，等一下，世界想让我成为流行歌星。
You just kind of went that way for a while? Yes, I mean, I was, I am a theater nerd through and through and you know, this very insane journey with music kind of took over my life for a very long time through and through. Yeah, it was just crazy because when I was younger, especially after doing 13 on Broadway, I was kind of like, how cool, I get to be part of the theater community. I can't wait to be like the understudy for the Thoroughly Modern Millie revival and maybe be in the ensemble on the days when I'm not being the swing. And then I'll do music on the side and hopefully someone will listen to it and that can be like a little side thing
你就那样走了一段时间？是的，我是说，我是一个彻头彻尾的戏剧书呆子，你知道，这段非常疯狂的音乐之旅在很长一段时间里接管了我的生活。对，这太疯狂了，因为当我年轻的时候，特别是在百老汇演完《13》之后，我心想，太酷了，我能成为戏剧社区的一员。我迫不及待想成为《Thoroughly Modern Millie》复排版的替补，也许在我不做替补的日子里在群演里。然后我会在业余时间做音乐，希望有人会听，那可以像个副业
and hopefully someone will be into it. These are all things that are on Sean's, yeah, they're all on Sean's vision board. You just named everything that's on his vision board. Well then, speaking of theater then, musical theater, was there, what was it like the first time you saw Wicked on Broadway? Was that?
希望有人会喜欢。这些都是肖恩愿望清单上的东西，对，都在肖恩的愿望清单上。好吧，说到戏剧，音乐剧，那是怎样的，你第一次在百老汇看《魔法坏女巫》是什么感觉？那是？
I mean, it was life changing. It was literally life before and after seeing Wicked, my life in two chapters. Did you see it with Idina Menzel and Chenoweth? I did, I was very spoiled, I can't believe I got to, I saw it with the original Broadway cast. When was that? And I was 10.
我是说，那是改变人生的。那真的是看《魔法坏女巫》之前和之后，我人生的两个篇章。你是和伊迪娜·门泽尔还有切诺维斯一起看的吗？是的，我非常幸运，我不敢相信我能，我是和百老汇原版卡司一起看的。那是什么时候？我当时10岁。
Was it like 10 years ago? Yeah. Oh, 20 years ago. 20 years ago. 21. 21 years ago. Wow, wow, crazy. Yeah, it was crazy. I mean, it changed my life.
是10年前吗？对。哦，20年前。20年前。21。21年前。哇，哇，疯狂。对，太疯狂了。我是说，它改变了我的人生。
I was so obsessed. And it's gotta be so surreal, like, yeah, seeing that, and then now you're in it, like, Glinda, it's wild. So then, can I ask then, did you hear that they were making a movie of Wicked and you threw your hat in the ring? Yes, that's putting it very lightly. Really? I was stalking Mark Platt. Like, I actually was like, literally in the bushes outside his house. Yes, that's putting it very lightly.
我太着迷了。而且这一定很超现实，就像，对，看到那个，然后现在你在里面，像，格琳达，太狂野了。那么，我可以问一下，你听说他们要拍《魔法坏女巫》电影，你就毛遂自荐了吗？是的，那说得太轻描淡写了。真的吗？我一直在跟踪马克·普拉特。就像，我实际上就像，真的在他家外面的灌木丛里。是的，那说得太轻描淡写了。
I was stalking Mark Platt. I wasn't, but maybe I was. I was on the Sweetener tour and I had heard murmurs of, okay, this thing is gearing up to happen and I told my team, I was like, hey, we're going to have to have a plan. I don't know what to do. But if God forbid, if God forbid I'm still on the road when this thing starts happening, we are going to have to like, you know, refund some tickets, pay everyone working on the tour to just like, you know, here's what you whatever go away. I have to figure this out.
我一直在跟踪马克·普拉特。我没有，但也许我有。我在“Sweetener”巡演期间，我听到了一些传闻，好的，这件事正在筹备中，我告诉我的团队，我说，嘿，我们得有个计划。我不知道该怎么办。但如果上帝保佑，如果上帝保佑这件事开始发生时我还在路上，我们得，你知道，退掉一些票，付钱给巡演的所有工作人员，让他们，你知道，这是你的什么什么，走开。我得搞定这个。
I have to, I have to give my everything to this my full-time gig, I have to do everything in my power just to get a chance to earn it. I want to make sure that when my audition, if I get an audition, that I'm fucking ready with every... Did they make you audition? Yeah, I mean, of course it's wicked. Of course it's wicked. Would you have to do like a self-tape
我得，我得把我的全部投入到这个全职工作中，我得尽我所能去争取一个机会来赢得它。我想确保当我的试镜，如果我得到试镜的话，我他妈的准备好了，带着每一个……他们让你试镜了吗？对，我是说，当然是《魔法坏女巫》。当然是《魔法坏女巫》。你得做那种自录视频吗
or did you go in there in person? No, you go in. On your phone. I mean, it was such a, it was a thorough experience as it should be. I mean, I think, you know, there's just so much that is required of Glinda that's so different from what I usually do.
还是你亲自去了那里？不，你得去。在你的手机上。我是说，那是一个，那是一个彻底的体验，理应如此。我是说，我想，你知道，格琳达需要的东西太多了，和我通常做的非常不同。
I am Ariana, I'm five foot six, I'm from New York, and this is my first. Wow, five six, do I present five six? I wish, oh my God, wow. Wait, what's amazing though? You're five six presenting. And this is my first. Wow, 5'6", do I present 5'6"? I wish, oh my God, wow. No, I'm sorry. What's amazing though. You're 5'6' presenting.
我是爱莉安娜，我五英尺六英寸，我来自纽约，这是我的第一次。哇，五英尺六英寸，我看起来有五英尺六英寸吗？我希望，哦，天哪，哇。等等，什么很棒？你五英尺六英寸。这是我的第一次。哇，5'6"，我看起来有5'6"吗？我希望，哦，天哪，哇。不，抱歉。什么很棒。你5'6"看起来。
5'6' presenting, no, sorry. What's amazing though about what you just said about having to audition and show up and show your, I was just blown, everybody knows you can sing and sing really well. Thank you, that's amazing. But to be able to legit sing like that, like you, like, we both go, we both see Eric Vitro.
5'6"看起来，不，抱歉。关于你刚才说的必须试镜并展示你的，这很棒，每个人都知道你能唱歌，而且唱得非常好。谢谢，那太棒了。但能合法地像那样唱歌，像你，像，我们都去，我们都看埃里克·维特罗。
Eric taught me how to sing and he coaches you and he's the greatest vocal coach ever. In the world, yeah. Yes, and to watch you, like, I was talking to Jason and Will about the athleticism of your voice and Cynthia's voice and like what that requires, I'm watching you on screen like breathing with you like as you and then the legit like diaphragm like the power you have is so incredible
埃里克教我如何唱歌，他指导你，他是最伟大的声乐教练。在世界上，对。是的，看着你，就像，我正在和杰森还有威尔谈论你的声音和辛西娅声音的运动能力，以及那需要什么，我在屏幕上看着你，和你一起呼吸，就像你，然后合法的横膈膜，就像你拥有的力量太不可思议了
and you can't teach it, you know? Thank you, that is so nice. Sean, is it, Arianna, is there a, when you're dancing and singing at the same time, do you constantly have to monitor not running out of breath because you're dancing? Like you need the breath for singing, but you also need to, you're like,
而且你教不会，你知道吗？谢谢，那太好了。肖恩，是，爱莉安娜，有没有，当你跳舞和唱歌同时进行时，你是否必须不断监控不要因为跳舞而喘不过气来？就像你需要呼吸来唱歌，但你也需要，你就像，
you're exercising with dancing too. Is that a challenge? Well yeah, I thought I, it's just kind of something that you build up to. So there's a lot of physical training. There's like, you know, whatever you can do, cardio pilates every morning, then before the rehearsals, hopefully it feels like a little easier.
你也在通过跳舞锻炼。那是个挑战吗？嗯，对，我以为我，这只是你逐渐建立起来的东西。所以有很多体能训练。有，你知道，任何你能做的，每天早上的有氧普拉提，然后在排练之前，希望感觉容易一点。
Like the more you do ahead of it, the more it's easier to, you know, singing on the treadmill. Do you sing on the treadmill to get used to it? Sometimes, yeah. Yeah, I didn't know how. But you know, I was thinking that like, all that training that you did, again, you started in the theater and then you kind of,
就像你在它之前做得越多，就越容易，你知道，在跑步机上唱歌。你在跑步机上唱歌来习惯它吗？有时，对。对，我不知道怎么做。但你知道，我在想，你做的所有那些训练，再次，你从戏剧开始，然后你有点，
you know, became this huge pop star but maintained that love for theater. I wonder if, and I'm asking, I guess, being on tour and singing and performing in front of big, huge audiences must have been all those years turns out was maybe great preparation, was it? Yeah, it's funny because I feel like it's like, yes, but also I feel like working with Jason Robert Brown at the age of 13 was my preparation for that. I was like, oh my goodness, the only reason I can keep up with this tour where I'm singing all of these songs live for two and a half hours every night or however long it is or whatever it is, that it's very demanding and then traveling on a dry bus or in a dry plane
你知道，成为了这个巨大的流行歌星，但保持了对戏剧的热爱。我想知道，我在问，我想，巡演和在大型观众面前唱歌表演，一定是你这些年来证明可能是伟大的准备，是吗？对，很有趣，因为我觉得就像，是的，但也觉得在13岁时和杰森·罗伯特·布朗一起工作是我为那个做的准备。我心想，哦，天哪，我能跟上这个巡演的唯一原因是我每晚都在现场唱所有这些歌，持续两个半小时，或者无论多久，或者无论它是什么，它非常苛刻，然后在干燥的巴士或干燥的飞机上旅行
or whatever it is. that it's very demanding and then traveling on a dry bus or in a dry plane or whatever it is. The only reason I can keep up with that, I credit to being on Broadway. So it goes back and forth kind of. It's just this stamina that I am so grateful that I got to build at a young age because Jason gave me the hard, I couldn't, I love Jason Robert Brown because he is like, can you do that? And it's like, I don't know. And he's like, you got it.
或者无论它是什么。它非常苛刻，然后在干燥的巴士或干燥的飞机上旅行，或者无论它是什么。我能跟上它的唯一原因，我归功于在百老汇。所以它来回往复。这只是这种耐力，我非常感激能在年轻时建立起来，因为杰森给了我困难的，我不能，我爱杰森·罗伯特·布朗，因为他就像，你能做到吗？而这就像，我不知道。而他就像，你做到了。
And it's just like, okay, great, I figure it out. Because he said you got it, you got it, yeah. Yeah, it's like a second longer of a note than you think you can hold, or a higher note, one note higher than you think you can sing. And he's like, perfect, you take that harmony. And I think that trained me to be able to do the singing that I was doing,
而这就像，好的，太棒了，我搞定了。因为他说你做到了，你做到了，对。对，就像比你认为你能保持的音符长一秒，或者比你认为你能唱的音符高一个音。而他就像，完美，你拿走那个和声。而我认为那训练了我能够做我正在做的唱歌，
and then it went back and forth, I suppose. And forgive the term legit, because it's all legit. Even pop singing is legit. No, I know what you mean. You know what I mean. So, do you want to do more of that? Because I'd never seen you do that until Wicked. I'd never seen you sing legit like that.
然后它来回往复，我想。原谅“合法”这个词，因为一切都是合法的。即使流行歌曲也是合法的。不，我知道你的意思。你知道我的意思。所以，你想做更多那样的事吗？因为在《魔法坏女巫》之前我从没见过你那样做。我从没见过你那样合法地唱歌。
Well, you know, it felt really wonderful to kind of have a little surprise. And so it was really special for me. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. Backing up a little bit, the start of your career was great.
嗯，你知道，有一点小惊喜感觉真的很棒。所以对我来说真的很特别。对。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。稍微回顾一下，你职业生涯的开始很棒。
So you do like this big musical on Broadway. You start doing some acting and that really takes off as far as kid success goes, like you're killing it because you're on a big series, I think on Nickelodeon perhaps. and all the while you're thinking and dreaming and trying for some singing as well and that's really the passion and your team is probably, I'm assuming, kind of supportive yes but not really sure, well should we throw the baby out with the bath water, can we do
所以你在百老汇做了一部大音乐剧。你开始做一些表演，就儿童成功而言，那真的起飞了，就像你表现出色，因为你在一个大系列剧里，我想也许是在尼克频道。而与此同时，你也在思考、梦想并尝试一些唱歌，那确实是激情所在，你的团队可能，我假设，有点支持，是的，但不确定，好吧，我们应该把孩子和洗澡水一起倒掉吗，我们可以做
both? Like what was the thing in singing, what was the big success that gave you comfort and your team comfort that you could kind of transition away from acting a little bit more and really pursue this musical career? Well I think it just kind of, I followed it in a way. Because you know, the whole time I was a cat on Nickelodeon, I was also writing like pop R&B music on the side.
两者吗？就像唱歌方面的事情，什么大成功给了你安慰，也给了你团队安慰，让你能够稍微从表演中过渡出来，真正追求这个音乐事业？嗯，我想它只是，我以某种方式跟随它。因为你知道，我在尼克频道演猫咪的整个时间里，我也在业余时间写流行R&B音乐。
I would go from set to the studio and I would be making these songs that I was probably too young to put out yet. And it was just a funny, interesting thing. And I remember there was a blurry time when Nickelodeon kind of wanted the music that I was writing to potentially be for the show. So there was a moment where I actually put out a song with a red hair and it was very kind of in the Cat Valentine mindset because I didn't know if I was supposed to be myself yet or not.
我会从片场去录音室，我会制作这些我可能还太年轻而不能发布的歌。那是一件有趣、有趣的事情。我记得有一段模糊的时间，尼克频道有点想要我写的音乐，可能用于节目。所以有一个时刻，我实际上发布了一首红头发的歌，那非常像猫咪瓦伦丁的心态，因为我不知道我是否应该做我自己。
And then someone that I was very close to that was very supportive and a really, really, really loving, wonderful person in my life was like, hey, they're going to love you as you, with brown hair, singing R&B inspired pop, and just fucking wing it and put that out. And I did, and it was really cool. It was cool to see the people not know the connection or discover that and then realize the connection.
然后一个我非常亲近的人，非常支持我，在我生命中是一个非常、非常、非常充满爱、很棒的人，他说，嘿，他们会爱上原本的你，棕色头发，唱着R&B风格的流行乐，就他妈的随性而为，把它发布出来。我做了，那真的很酷。看到人们不知道这种联系，或者发现它，然后意识到这种联系，这很酷。
They accepted you. It was just cool. Yeah, it was scary but cool and I've learned a lot along the way. It's weird. Oh, that's great. What you've done, and again, you've done this, in the music space and the acting space and the combo with the musicals. And now, as Jason said, when he interviewed you,
他们接受了你。那真的很酷。对，这很吓人但很酷，我一路上学到了很多。这很奇怪。哦，那太棒了。你所做的，再次，你已经做到了，在音乐领域和表演领域，以及与音乐剧的结合。现在，正如杰森所说，当他采访你时，
you're getting into other businesses and cosmetics, I guess, and a lot of other things. Like you're taking on a lot of, are those other things giving you that same, are you getting that same sort of like hunger for success in those other areas? Are you finding that same sort of hunger for success in those other areas? Are you finding them rewarding, getting into business and doing stuff like that?
你正在进入其他业务和化妆品，我想，还有很多其他事情。就像你承担了很多，那些其他事情给了你同样的，你是否在那些其他领域获得了同样的成功渴望？你是否在那些其他领域找到了同样的成功渴望？你觉得它们有回报吗，进入商业并做那样的事情？
Has that been a fun experience? It's definitely been a fun experience. And I definitely love creating in all capacities and storytelling in any capacity. I really do love my fragrance and my beauty brand and that stuff is like, it's really fun. And I think it's a totally different part of my brain. My mom is a CEO and she's very much a business person.
那是一次有趣的经历吗？这绝对是一次有趣的经历。而且我绝对喜欢在所有能力范围内创造，以及在任何能力范围内讲故事。我真的非常喜欢我的香水和美容品牌，那些东西就像，真的很有趣。而且我认为这是我大脑中完全不同的部分。我妈妈是CEO，她非常是一个商业人士。
My dad is an artist, so I think I kind of sit exactly in between the two of them and these two parts of me are very hungry in very different ways and I enjoy it. I enjoy creating, but I think obviously my loves of my are very hungry in very different ways and I enjoy it. I enjoy creating but I think obviously my loves of my life are acting in music. It's not even a comparison. I feel grateful for every area in which I can be
我爸爸是艺术家，所以我认为我有点正好坐在他们两人之间，这两个部分的我以非常不同的方式感到饥渴，我很享受。我很享受创造，但我认为显然我生命中的爱是表演和音乐。这甚至无法比较。我为每一个我能成为
a creative person who makes stuff. But it's not necessarily the same, but it's something I love very much. You know, when you said earlier about, with the music you weren't really sure if you were allowed to be you, and it's sort of a weird question, but with all of the success that you are having
一个创造性的人并制作东西的领域感到感激。但这不一定是一样的，但这是我非常热爱的东西。你知道，当你早些时候说，关于音乐你不太确定是否被允许做你自己，这是一个有点奇怪的问题，但随着你正在拥有的所有成功
and have had in all of these different areas, all of those things can be really affecting on who you are, obviously to the public, but really who you are internally because they can kind of pull you and push you into areas of yourself you would like to be or areas that you really didn't think that you were or at least the perception of you.
并且在所有这些不同领域都有过，所有这些事情都可能对你是谁产生真正的影响，显然是对公众，但真正是对你内在的，因为它们可以有点拉扯你，把你推向你想要成为的自己领域，或者你真的没认为你是的领域，或者至少是对你的看法。
So, excuse me, how are you managing keeping a natural sort of progression of who you are, who you would like to be as far as letting these outside things identify who you are? And does that make any sense? No, it makes total sense and it's also something that I have to be so protective of. Because I think like as an artist, the most important thing is authenticity and kind of making the records that I want to make.
所以，打扰一下，你是如何管理保持一个自然的你，你想要成为的你，就让这些外部事物定义你是谁而言？这有意义吗？不，这完全有意义，而且这也是我必须非常保护的东西。因为我认为作为一个艺术家，最重要的事情是真实性，以及制作我想制作的唱片。
Talking about the things, singing about the things that mean something to you, right? Totally, but you know, I also am like a cancer and a recovering people pleaser, and I like, in the past, oh yeah, hi, hello. Recovering people pleaser. I I like, in the past, oh yeah, yeah, hi, hello. Recovering people pleaser. I am, I am, I am. I wish there were a group, oh my God, I'm meeting.
谈论那些事情，唱那些对你有意义的事情，对吧？完全是，但你知道，我也是一个巨蟹座，一个正在康复的讨好型人格，我喜欢，在过去，哦，是的，嗨，你好。正在康复的讨好型人格。我喜欢，在过去，哦，是的，是的，嗨，你好。正在康复的讨好型人格。我是，我是，我是。我希望有一个小组，哦，天哪，我正在见面。
Let's start, just me and you. Let's go, please, I'm serious. Hang on one second, so Jason, pleasing people is something, okay, how do you phrase this? But no, I feel like- That is such a great term. But it's true, it's such a thing that we have to fight to protect as people who have a connection with our listeners, our fans, and also remaining true to ourselves and what's in our hearts.
让我们开始，就我和你。让我们走吧，拜托，我是认真的。等一下，所以杰森，讨好别人是一件事，好的，你怎么表达这个？但不，我觉得——那是一个很好的词。但这确实是真的，这是我们作为与听众、粉丝有联系的人，同时保持对自己和内心真实的人，必须努力保护的东西。
And I feel like I've been doing a really great job at that recently, but it's just such a hard line to walk. It's like, no, I'm going to write the songs I want to write. I have to make the album that I want to make, and I have to kind of tune as much of the noise out so that I can just be an honest person, which has been hard work, especially when you come into it at 19, sorry. No, that's great.
而且我觉得我最近在这方面做得很好，但这真是一条很难走的线。就像，不，我要写我想写的歌。我必须制作我想制作的专辑，我必须尽可能地调低噪音，这样我才能做一个诚实的人，这很辛苦，特别是当你19岁进入这个行业时，抱歉。不，那太棒了。
You know, I was thinking too, like, total, by the way, exact same person. Long-winded, I'm like so long- at 19, sorry. No, that's great. You know, I was thinking too, like, total, by the way, exact same person. Long-winded, I'm like so long-winded, sorry. No, same. No, that's what you're for. No, yeah. And we're going to cut all of it out. So the, I'm kidding.
你知道，我也在想，完全，顺便说一句，完全一样的人。长篇大论，我太长篇大论了，抱歉。不，一样。不，这就是你的目的。不，是的。我们要把这一切都剪掉。所以，我开玩笑的。
My whole, just my whole presence. Cut the whole presence. No, no, no. Sorry, he's going to ask you questions, so get ready to think of your favorite colors right now. Go ahead, Chuck. Or something weird happened on stage, maybe. Something weird happened in the theater colors right now. Go ahead, Sean. Or something weird happened on stage. Something weird happened in the theater.
我的整个，只是我的整个存在。剪掉整个存在。不，不，不。抱歉，他要问你问题，所以准备好现在想你最喜欢的颜色。继续，查克。或者舞台上发生了奇怪的事情，也许。剧院里发生了奇怪的事情。继续，肖恩。或者舞台上发生了奇怪的事情。剧院里发生了奇怪的事情。
Oh yeah, well. Anybody ever get lippy in the audience? Oh my God, I could talk to you for 17,000 hours about that. Go ahead, Sean, then do it. No, Ariana, like in the back of your head, get like a great theater story ready, because I love those. Like things that go wrong, like I have so many of them.
哦，是的，好吧。有人在观众席上顶嘴吗？哦，天哪，我可以和你谈论那个17000个小时。继续，肖恩，那就做吧。不，爱莉安娜，就像在你的脑海里，准备一个伟大的戏剧故事，因为我喜欢那些。就像出错的事情，我有那么多。
But, but. Still did it, did it anyway. Yeah, well, did it anyway. I have, well, you get it ready. So I want to talk about like getting, do you have a, what is it like with the, how do you handle the ups and downs of being, I hate saying this, but relevant, because for example, like Taylor Swift,
但是，但是。还是做了，无论如何都做了。是的，好吧，无论如何都做了。我有，好吧，你准备好。所以我想谈谈，你是否有，你是如何处理作为，我讨厌说这个，但相关，因为例如，像泰勒·斯威夫特，
like I don't remember anybody talking about her five, six, seven, eight, nine years ago. I mean, sure, she had many, many fans and she was very famous and popular, but she wasn't like she is now. And it goes up and down and up and down for everybody in this entire entertainment business. And so for me, I've always been a huge fan of yours,
就像我不记得五、六、七、八、九年前有人谈论她。我是说，当然，她有很多很多粉丝，她非常出名和受欢迎，但她不像现在这样。而且这对整个娱乐业的每个人来说都是起起落落。所以对我来说，我一直是你的超级粉丝，
but Wicked really like, oh my God, there's Ariana Grande and everything. And it's not that people didn't think that when you had an album come out or a tour come out, but the ups and downs when you're quiet. Yeah, there's spikes. Yeah, there's those spikes. How do you handle or what do you do during the low spikes?
但《魔法坏女巫》真的让人觉得，天哪，有爱莉安娜·格兰德还有其他一切。并不是说人们在你有专辑或巡演发布时不会这么想，但在你沉寂的时候，那些起起落落……是的，确实有高峰。是的，确实有那些高峰。你是如何应对的，或者在低谷期你会做什么？
I don't know. I mean, I try not to look at spikes or for them or monitor them. Yeah, very good. I kind of try to, I think I'm'm a person who wasn't meant to be famous, but I love the art of making and creating so much that I think my insatiable need to just make things and create and try to push myself to grow
我不知道。我的意思是，我尽量不去关注那些高峰，不去寻找它们，也不去监测它们。是的，非常好。我试着……我觉得我是一个本不该出名的人，但我太热爱创作和制造艺术了，以至于我认为我那种想要不断创造、不断尝试推动自己成长、
in different directions and learn new things and see what I can. I kind of try to focus on that as much as possible and I think it helps me survive. Otherwise I really think if I paid more attention that I would go away. I think it's just too scary. Well you're adding layers to it too, which is really cool.
向不同方向发展、学习新事物并看看自己能做到什么的贪婪需求，我尽量把注意力集中在这些事情上，我认为这有助于我生存。否则，我真的觉得如果我投入更多关注，我就会崩溃。我觉得这太可怕了。嗯，你也在为它增加层次，这真的很酷。
You're adding different dimensions to what you do. So it's like people can't just go like, what is Ariana Grande? They're not like, oh she's just a pop star. No, she's an actress. That's such a scary thought to even think like, oh what are they thinking right now? Like the healthiest thing for me is to disconnect as much as humanly possible. Of course I have like the internet and I'm on my phone. I love Instagram, but I'm a person who tries
你正在为你所做的事情增加不同的维度。所以人们不能只是说，爱莉安娜·格兰德是什么？他们不会说，哦，她只是个流行歌星。不，她是一位演员。甚至去想“哦，他们现在在想什么？”都是一个可怕的想法。对我来说，最健康的事情就是尽可能地与外界断开联系。当然，我有互联网，我也用手机。我喜欢 Instagram，但我是一个试图
to maintain a healthy distance from it. It's like the same thing I would tell a young person who's like, what do you do when you hear no all the time? Those spikes feel like big nos again. It feels like I didn't get a call back for a chitty chitty bang bang and I'm eight years old or something. Like it's the same thing.
与它保持健康距离的人。这就像我会告诉一个年轻人的一样，当你一直听到“不”的时候该怎么办？那些高峰感觉又像是巨大的“不”。感觉就像我八岁时去试镜《飞天万能车》没被叫回去一样。就像是同一回事。
But I'm serious. It's the same feeling. As you add those layers and you have those moments, what are the things then now as you kind of look forward and go like, okay, I've done that. What are the new targets? Do you have new targets in mind? Yeah, how do you define success nowadays? Yeah, yeah, exactly new, do you have new targets? How do you define success nowadays?
但我说真的。那是同一种感觉。当你增加那些层次并拥有那些时刻时，当你展望未来并想，“好吧，我已经做到了。新的目标是什么？”你心中有新的目标吗？是的，你现在如何定义成功？是的，是的，没错，你有新的目标吗？你现在如何定义成功？
Yeah, yeah, exactly, how do you find success? Oh my goodness, I, first of all, all of you have to answer this hard ass question after I'm done. Everyone has to answer, we're taking turns. This is the first official meeting of people pleasing recovery. I'll bet it's somewhere around, are you able to maintain happiness and calm and peace
是的，是的，没错，你如何定义成功？天哪，首先，在我说完之后，你们所有人都必须回答这个难题。每个人都必须回答，我们轮流来。这是“讨好型人格康复”的第一次正式会议。我敢说这大概是关于，你是否能够在每天面对如此复杂、充满挑战的事情时，
and harmony each day amidst so much complicated, challenging kind of stuff. And noise. Yeah, I suppose it's like, yeah. I mean, amen to that. I mean, how can we find that balance, maintain that balance, but also like, is the work that I'm taking on something
保持快乐、冷静、平和与和谐。还有噪音。是的，我想是这样。我的意思是，对此表示赞同。我的意思是，我们如何找到那种平衡，保持那种平衡，但同时，我所承担的工作是否是
that can challenge me, that I can grow from, that I haven't done before, that I'm learning from, that I'm giving like to the character in the same way that it's maybe going to teach me or feed me, I don't know. And maybe success is the experience of creating and not the result of. Right, totally. Maybe it's like.
能挑战我、让我从中成长、我以前没做过、我能从中学习、我能像它可能教导我或滋养我一样去赋予角色的东西，我不知道。也许成功是创造的体验，而不是结果。对，完全正确。也许是这样。
I don't think so. Okay. Yeah, I mean, it's probably true with anybody on the planet, no matter what industry or occupation they're in, if you can maintain happiness each day, because it's such a slippery thing, right? JB, we talk about it all the time, which is this notion of, look, we have the benefit, I'm, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good,
我不这么认为。好吧。是的，我的意思是，这对于地球上的任何人来说可能都是真的，无论他们从事什么行业或职业，如果你能每天保持快乐，因为这太容易溜走了，对吧？JB，我们一直在谈论它，也就是这个概念，看，我们有这个优势，我，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，
good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good,
好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，
good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good, good of what I do professionally. So how I feel is not a reflection of what I do. I've really been able to separate those things up because if I try as hard as I can to not be at the effect of circumstances, if I'm only happy if it's sunny out, then what the fuck happens when it rains? Then I'm fucked.
好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，好，关于我职业生涯所做的事情。所以我感觉如何并不是我所做之事的反映。我真的能够把这些事情分离开来，因为如果我尽我所能不去受环境的影响，如果我只有在天气晴朗时才快乐，那么下雨时该死地会发生什么？那我就完了。
So I gotta figure out a way to be happy no matter what. And those are sometimes just the smallest things. And family, we all have kids, so it's like my relationship with my kids, if my kids are happy, then I'm happy, all that kind of stuff, those are the things that really come to the forefront and become important, my relationship with my friends.
所以我必须想办法无论如何都要快乐。这些有时只是最小的事情。还有家庭，我们都有孩子，所以就像我和我孩子的关系，如果我的孩子快乐，那我就快乐，所有这些事情，这些才是真正浮出水面并变得重要的事情，我和朋友的关系。
Yeah, stuff you can control. Stuff you can control, but also stuff that's really, that's for real important. You know, my relationship with these guys is very important. Staying connected, talking about what's going on, all that kind of stuff. And everything else, when you kind of right size
是的，你可以控制的事情。你可以控制的事情，但也是真正重要的、真实的事情。你知道，我和这些家伙的关系非常重要。保持联系，谈论正在发生的事情，所有这些事情。而其他一切，当你把
all that other stuff, it feels so much better. I don't know if you guys agree, but it does for me. For sure, yeah. I fully agree. Yeah, and Arianna, I know you didn't ask for this, but you've gotten it because you are seemingly such a kind and easily likable, lovable person, not to mention your success,
所有其他事情调整到合适的位置时，感觉会好得多。我不知道你们是否同意，但对我来说是这样。当然，是的。我完全同意。是的，爱莉安娜，我知道你没要求这个，但你得到了它，因为你看起来是一个如此善良、容易让人喜欢、可爱的人，更不用说你的成功了，
but the youth really looks up to you and follows you. And so how do you manage that sort of responsibility that again, you didn't sign up for, but you've got it. Do you think about that like when you're writing lyrics or when you're taking on roles or is any of that factor in? No, I mean, yeah, I mean, here's the thing. Probably not an effort because you're just naturally sort of a decent person and they're
但年轻人确实很仰慕你并追随你。那么你是如何管理那种你并没有报名参加，但却拥有的责任的呢？当你写歌词或接角色时，你会考虑这些吗？或者这些因素有影响吗？不，我的意思是，是的，我的意思是，事情是这样的。可能不是刻意的，因为你天生就是一个正派的人，他们
going to follow a good example. I mean that's very generous and kind. I just feel like it's kind of a really specific and strange thing to become a public person at like a really young age and then to have kind of all this normal growth that happens in everyone's twenties and young teen years and whatever it is in front of an audience and in front of people who, you know, don't have to have every mistake that they've ever made flash in front of them and like remind it every two seconds. It's like, it's interesting. It's like a funky thing. But you know, all we can actually do is grow and be human.
会追随一个好的榜样。我的意思是，这非常慷慨和善良。我只是觉得在很年轻的时候成为一个公众人物，然后让所有这些在二十多岁和青少年时期发生的正常成长过程都在观众面前，在那些不必让每一个犯过的错误都在他们面前闪现并每两秒提醒一次的人面前发生，这是一种非常具体且奇怪的事情。这很有趣。这是一种古怪的事情。但你知道，我们实际上能做的只有成长和做人。
Become more and more human, I think, in the face of being dehumanized and objectified. We can just become more and more human, I guess. Well, that's interesting. Again, it sounds like there's some kind of international incident going on outside your hotel. Yeah, are you somewhere in the middle? They're going to find you, Ariana. But, but, but, but, you bring up a, that must be interesting in a very unique situation and something that's been talked about
我认为，在被非人化和客体化的过程中，变得越来越有人情味。我想，我们只能变得越来越有人情味。嗯，这很有趣。再说一次，听起来你酒店外面好像发生了什么国际事件。是的，你在中间吗？他们会找到你的，爱莉安娜。但是，但是，但是，你提出了一个，那一定是一个非常独特的情况，而且是已经被讨论过的事情，
and obviously JB was a, Jason was a performer when he was young and grew up, grew up in that world as well in a different way, but. Singing and dancing. Singing and dancing, his two, if you want to, if you want Jason to die on the spot, tell him he's gotta sing and dance and he will expire in front of you.
显然 JB 是一个，杰森年轻时也是一名表演者，也在那个世界里以不同的方式成长，但是。唱歌跳舞。唱歌跳舞，他的两项，如果你想，如果你想让杰森当场死亡，告诉他他必须唱歌跳舞，他就会在你面前断气。
Give a toast. Give a toast, while giving a toast. Yeah, giving a toast. But, Arianna, to go through your 20s with that kind of scrutiny, talk a little bit about that. I can't imagine, I think about, you guys, think about all the dumb shit you did in your 20s, and then imagine growing up in this world,
敬酒。敬酒，在敬酒的时候。是的，敬酒。但是，爱莉安娜，在那种审视下度过你的 20 多岁，谈谈那个吧。我无法想象，我想你们，想想你们 20 多岁时做的所有蠢事，然后想象在这个世界里成长，
the digital era, where everything is, people got an opinion on it, it gets broadcast, I mean. Yeah, people got phones to record you when you're not looking. Yeah, it must be really hard to get your head around it and get your heart around it and all of it. Yeah, I mean, I'm a very sensitive person. So I can't say it's something that I have done particularly well with. Well, it's okay.
数字时代，一切都是，人们对此有意见，它被广播，我的意思是。是的，人们有手机在你没注意的时候录下你。是的，要理解这一切并接受这一切一定非常困难。是的，我的意思是，我是一个非常敏感的人。所以我不能说我处理得特别好。嗯，没关系。
But it's also something that I have had the help of, you know, my loved ones and therapy and time and art and just a love for, and also a deep sense of gratitude for what I am so privileged to be able to do. That has kind of gotten me through it. Every time I kind of experienced that, I just kind of had to disconnect, I suppose, for a little. Because, again, back to the cancer people-pleasing, there was always a part of me that wanted to kind of explain
但这也是我得到了我的爱人、治疗、时间和艺术的帮助，以及对我所能做的特权工作的深深感激之情的事情。这让我度过了难关。每次我经历那种情况时，我想我只是不得不暂时断开连接。因为，再说一次，回到那个“讨好型人格”，我内心总有一部分想要去解释
or do a big, you know, come talk to the world and come talk to everyone about what the truth is and whatever it is that I'm experiencing, that whatever, or explain things, and overshare, you know, for the sake of being understood by a humongous thing of strangers. for the sake of being understood by a humongous thing of strangers. And it's just a strange thing to feel at such a young age,
或者做一个大的，你知道，出来和世界谈谈，出来和每个人谈谈真相是什么，或者我正在经历什么，无论是什么，或者解释事情，并且过度分享，你知道，为了被一大群陌生人理解。为了被一大群陌生人理解。在这么年轻的时候有这种感觉是一件奇怪的事情，
and what is the boundary there, and what's a healthy relationship to it, and how do you protect yourself for the sake of being able to continue. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, continue, and just to live. Yeah, yeah. For what it's worth, from the outside, it seems like you've, continuing, just to live. Yeah, yeah. For what it's worth from the outside,
那里的界限是什么，什么是健康的相处方式，为了能够继续下去，你如何保护自己？是的，是的，是的。嗯，继续下去，只是为了生活。是的，是的。不管怎么说，从外面看，看起来你已经，继续下去，只是为了生活。是的，是的。不管怎么说，从外面看，
it seems like you've done a fantastic job with that. I agree. I agree. Oh my God, that's so nice. And speaking of continuing, you know, like- Sean does not agree. No, I actually just texted you, Ariana, I texted you a bunch of thoughts.
你在这方面做得非常出色。我同意。我同意。天哪，太好了。说到继续，你知道，像——肖恩不同意。不，我其实刚给你发了短信，爱莉安娜，我给你发了一堆想法。
So, no, but speaking of continuing, like what I love about you amongst many things is your ability to surprise people with choices and things you do. So you go from Broadway, then you go to be a pop star, and then you're an actress, and then you do all of these things. But one of the things that was so surprising
所以，不，但说到继续，我喜欢你的一点，除了很多事情之外，就是你用选择和你做的事情给人们带来惊喜的能力。所以你从百老汇开始，然后成为流行歌星，然后你是一名演员，然后你做了所有这些事情。但其中一件如此令人惊讶的事情
was I don't think anybody knew how unbelievably hilarious you are. Like, and you're Saturday Night God, that's so nice. And you're Saturday Night Live, we like died laughing, and your Jennifer Coolidge impression, like all of your impressions are so incredible. How weird in the world, nobody knew you could do that. And so it's like, if we don't know you can do that,
是我认为没人知道你竟然如此令人难以置信地搞笑。就像，你的《周六夜现场》，天哪，太好了。你的《周六夜现场》，我们笑得要死，还有你模仿詹妮弗·库里奇，就像你所有的模仿都太不可思议了。世界上怎么会这么奇怪，没人知道你能做到这一点。所以就像，如果我们不知道你能做到这一点，
imagine the next hundred things you're going to do over the next 50 years or whatever. Yeah, exactly. I'm so excited. Can you give us a little Jennifer Coolidge? Hey, Jen, what... Jennifer, what... Why weren't you on...
想象一下你在未来 50 年或无论多久里要做的接下来的一百件事。是的，没错。我太兴奋了。你能给我们来一点詹妮弗·库里奇吗？嘿，詹，什么……詹妮弗，什么……你为什么没上……
Can she visit with us real quick? Can we get her to mess this you up? Why weren't you on the White Lotus, the sequel? The White Lotus, Jennifer. They fucking killed me off. They pushed me off a goddamn boat. Oh, my God. I's so good, right guys? No, I didn't want to die.
她能和我们快速聊聊吗？我们能让她把这搞砸吗？你为什么没上《白莲花度假村》的续集？《白莲花度假村》，詹妮弗。他们该死地把我写死了。他们把我从该死的船上推了下去。哦，天哪。太棒了，对吧伙计们？不，我不想死。
Jesus Christ. But I guess I'm dead. Oh my god. That's creepy. It's just close your eyes. Come back. So good. I love her.
天哪。但我猜我死了。哦，天哪。那太诡异了。只是闭上眼睛。回来。太棒了。我爱她。
I love her too. Shit, that's fucking flat out. Oh my god. Thank you so much. Sean, that must make you want to have talent, right? I mean, just hearing her do that. You. All I want is a little bit of talent.
我也爱她。该死，那真是太绝了。哦，天哪。非常感谢。肖恩，那一定让你想要拥有天赋，对吧？我的意思是，听到她那样做。你。我只想要一点点天赋。
I want to have a little bit of talent. I want to have a little bit of talent. I want to have a little bit of talent. I want to have a little bit of talent. I want to have a little bit of talent. I want to Wow. Sean, that must make you want to have talent, right? I mean, just hearing her do that. You. All I want is a hot dog. I can't do the music. Jesus Christ.
我想要有一点点天赋。我想要有一点点天赋。我想要有一点点天赋。我想要有一点点天赋。我想要有一点点天赋。我想要哇。肖恩，那一定让你想要拥有天赋，对吧？我的意思是，听到她那样做。你。我只想要一个热狗。我做不了音乐。天哪。
Ariana, so that reminds me, the whole voice thing, and like, what is the weirdest thing you do to prep your voice when you're about to go do a concert? Are you breathing a bunch of steam? Are you gargling milk? No, no. Never milk. What goes on? Different things call for different kind of routines and tools, I guess.
爱莉安娜，这让我想起了声音的事情，比如，当你准备去开演唱会时，你为了准备嗓子会做的最奇怪的事情是什么？你是在吸蒸汽吗？你在用牛奶漱口吗？不，不。绝对不是牛奶。发生了什么？不同的事情需要不同种类的常规和工具，我想。
I feel like, I don't know, I feel like a nerd, but if you need the extra, you can have a little vocal box where there's all of the lozenges and sprays and hydration things and whatever. But that's mostly if you're fatigued or have a cough or whatever it is. I think the thing that I do that perplexes people so much, and it's just so funny because if you're a person who uses their voice, you know about this, is if I have a long day of press or if I have to sing, I'll place it vocal placement to kind of preserve.
我觉得，我不知道，我觉得自己像个书呆子，但如果你需要额外的，你可以有一个小声乐盒，里面有所有的润喉糖、喷雾剂和补水的东西等等。但那主要是如果你疲劳或咳嗽或无论是什么。我认为我做的让人们感到困惑的事情，而且这太有趣了，因为如果你是一个使用嗓子的人，你就知道这一点，那就是如果我有一整天的媒体采访，或者如果我必须唱歌，我会进行声乐定位来保护嗓子。
But that is just kind of something that's healthy for the voice and whatever. That's something I do. Because staying higher gives less stress on it than talking in a lower register? Yeah, so it's just like basically pitching your voice up a tiny bit. I agree, that's what I do.
但这只是对嗓子健康有益的事情等等。这是我做的事情。因为保持较高的音调比用较低的音域说话对嗓子的压力更小？是的，所以这基本上就是把你的声音稍微调高一点。我同意，这就是我做的。
I do the same thing. Yeah, but, yeah. Yeah, but it's just a normal thing for vocalists, but people are like, that's not her natural voice. And I'm like, well, it is actually, but it's just a little higher because it's, all of it is natural. And it's so funny, because we talked about it
我也做同样的事情。是的，但是，是的。是的，但这对于歌手来说是很正常的事情，但人们却说，那不是她自然的声音。我说，嗯，其实是，但它只是高了一点，因为它是，这一切都是自然的。这太有趣了，因为我们谈论过它
a zillion times and people are still like, where's your real voice? And I'm like, well, they're all, they all are, so it's just interesting. Yeah, do you sing every day? No, sometimes, I mean, casually, yeah. Actually, now that I think about it, I'm kind of insufferable to be around because I do sing all the time every day.
无数次了，人们仍然说，你真正的声音在哪里？我说，嗯，它们都是，它们确实都是，所以这很有趣。是的，你每天都唱歌吗？不，有时，我的意思是，随意地，是的。其实，现在我想起来，我在身边时有点让人难以忍受，因为我每天都在唱歌。
And yeah, the answer is yes, not no. The answer is yes. I sing in the shower all the time. I wouldn't dare. All the time. What do you sing, Sean? I sing the national anthem. Can we get a little taste of it? the time. What do you sing, Sean? I sing the national anthem. Can we get a little taste of it?
是的，答案是肯定的，不是否定的。答案是肯定的。我一直在淋浴时唱歌。我不敢。一直都在。你唱什么，肖恩？我唱国歌。我们能尝尝味道吗？一直都在。你唱什么，肖恩？我唱国歌。我们能尝尝味道吗？
Can we have it? Go ahead, Sean. Just a little bit. And the rocket's red glare. The water trying to get back up into the faucet. That's gorgeous. I'm bursting in air. Right.
能给我们来一点吗？来吧，肖恩。就一点点。还有火箭的红光。水试图回到水龙头里。太美了。我在空中爆发。对。
You're welcome. Choices. I love it. So speaking of... He proved the law. Wow, wow, wow. The law. No. Hey. Hahaha.
不客气。选择。我喜欢它。所以说到……他证明了法律。哇，哇，哇。法律。不。嘿。哈哈哈。
We'll be right back. And back to the show. Speaking of routines, walk us through a typical day for you if nothing's on your plate. You have a completely free day. Ooh. Are you one that sleeps in? Do you like to read? Let's go through a typical day for you if nothing's on your plate. You have a completely free day. Are you one that sleeps in? Do you like to read? Are you watching dumb movies?
我们马上回来。回到节目。说到常规，如果没什么事要做，带我们了解一下你典型的一天。你有一个完全空闲的一天。哦。你是那种睡懒觉的人吗？你喜欢读书吗？带我们了解一下你典型的一天，如果没什么事要做。你有一个完全空闲的一天。你是那种睡懒觉的人吗？你喜欢读书吗？你在看愚蠢的电影吗？
If you got nothing on your plate, what's the day look like? Oh, I love this. I love to, well, I love to wake up early. I do. Like if I need it, I feel like my body will tell me. And I get like one sleep in a month. Like the whole month is relying on this one day
如果你没什么事要做，这一天是什么样的？哦，我喜欢这个。我喜欢，嗯，我喜欢早起。我确实。就像如果我需要，我觉得我的身体会告诉我。我一个月能睡一次懒觉。就像整个月都指望着这一天
where my body just decides that it's going to sleep and then it sleeps. You know what I mean? Like a really scary slumber. Like knock knock, is everyone okay? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good. Otherwise you're up at the crack of ice.
我的身体决定它要睡觉，然后它就睡了。你知道我的意思吗？就像一场非常可怕的沉睡。就像敲敲门，大家都还好吗？是的，是的，是的。是的，我很好，我很好，我很好。否则你就在黎明时分起床了。
Yeah, I just get up and I like to do my steps. I like to pace on the treadmill with my little iPad and I either like I'm playing a game, a virtual game, or I'm texting my team and like whatever. I'm very creative when I'm on the treadmill. So I have ideas and I'll send like crazy voice notes to Christian Breslauer, the director that I work with on all my music videos.
是的，我只是起床，我喜欢做我的步数。我喜欢在跑步机上带着我的小 iPad 踱步，我要么是在玩游戏，虚拟游戏，要么是在给我的团队发短信，无论什么。我在跑步机上时非常有创造力。所以我会有想法，我会给克里斯蒂安·布雷斯劳尔发疯狂的语音笔记，他是和我合作所有音乐录影带的导演。
I don't know, I always have ideas on the plane. I'll either be texting him or my stylist Mimi or my team. I'll be like, oh my God, we forgot to talk about this. I wanted to talk about this. It gets my brain going. I love to get my steps done early. And then I'll hang out. I'll either like, you're laughing at me already.
我不知道，我在飞机上总是有想法。我要么是在给他发短信，要么是给我的造型师咪咪或我的团队。我会说，哦，天哪，我们忘了谈这个了。我想谈谈这个。这让我的大脑运转起来。我喜欢早点完成我的步数。然后我会闲逛。我要么，你已经在笑我了。
I haven't even said anything. I like to cook. I like to play games with my family. I like to cook on the treadmill. No. What's your go-to dish? What do you cook best? Well, I'm vegan, so I like to make, yeah, I love to roast, like,
我还没说什么呢。我喜欢做饭。我喜欢和家人玩游戏。我喜欢在跑步机上做饭。不。你的拿手菜是什么？你最擅长做什么菜？嗯，我是纯素食者，所以我喜欢做，是的，我喜欢烤，比如，
mushrooms of different variants and make like a vegan pesto and make like, why you hate mushrooms? I like it. I don't eat mushrooms, I can't eat mushrooms. Tofu, sweet potatoes. I love to like. So then you can have pasta as a vegan, right?
不同品种的蘑菇，做一种纯素香蒜酱，做一种，你为什么讨厌蘑菇？我喜欢它。我不吃蘑菇，我不能吃蘑菇。豆腐，红薯。我喜欢像。所以作为纯素食者，你可以吃意大利面，对吧？
Yeah, yes. All right, so then you're doing the pesto with the pasta. I'm back in, I'm back in. Oh yeah, but I'm Italian, so we have to have that, you know. Do you spend any time over there in Italy? No, no actually. I haven't been since I was on tour, and I would love to in a more meaningful way,
是的，是的。好吧，那你就在做香蒜酱意大利面。我回来了，我回来了。哦，是的，但我也是意大利人，所以我们必须有那个，你知道。你在意大利待过一段时间吗？不，不，其实没有。我自从巡演后就没去过，我很想以更有意义的方式去，
because I get to have more time away. Because so much is required of you every day of your life in so many areas, are you a germ freak? Are you like, I can't get sick, I can't get sick? I am a little bit of a germ freak. I do maintain the mask stuff. Oh, you do? I love a mask.
因为我可以有更多的时间离开。因为你生命中的每一天在这么多领域都需要你做这么多事，你是细菌狂吗？你是那种，我不能生病，我不能生病吗？我确实有点细菌狂。我确实保持口罩之类的东西。哦，你真的吗？我喜欢口罩。
I've always been a little bit of a germ person, a little bit of a OCD germ person. Not like, more with mask than it is like obsessive compulsive purelling. But like, just kind of, I like to stay. Or like when you go in an elevator, do you take your sleeve and press the button with your sleeve?
我一直是一个有点细菌的人，一个有点强迫症的细菌人。不是那种，更多的是口罩而不是强迫性的洗手液。但就像，只是那种，我喜欢保持。或者当你走进电梯时，你会用袖子按按钮吗？
No, it's not that far, but I also like, would do that now that you mentioned it, I'm going to start doing it tomorrow. Wait, what about bare feet on a hotel floor? That's Jason's. I can do that, but also more. I'm sicker than you are. I said to Jason, we were just on vacation,
不，没那么夸张，但既然你提到了，我明天就会开始这样做。等等，酒店地板上的赤脚呢？那是杰森的。我可以那样做，但更多。我比你病得更重。我对杰森说，我们刚去度假，
and he was like, of course, every time you sit down to eat with Jason, he sits down, he orders, and then he gets up, and he leaves, and he comes back, and he's holding his hands like he's going into surgery, like a surgeon does. I wash them. I'm ready to eat. And then he says, oh, did you sit there,
他就像，当然，每次你和杰森坐下来吃饭，他坐下，他点餐，然后他起身，他离开，他回来，他拿着手就像他要去做手术一样，像外科医生那样。我洗了它们。我准备好吃了。然后他说，哦，你坐在那里，
you got your hand, and I go, is everybody else here, and there were like 20 of us, I go, is everybody else falling down on the ground sick? Is everybody got it? Do we all get infected? You might, yeah, you might. Today you might. Yeah, that is a scary thing to me
你拿着手，我说，还有别人在这里吗，我们有 20 个人，我说，还有别人倒在地上生病吗？每个人都得了？我们都被感染了吗？你可能会，是的，你今天可能会。是的，这对我来说是一件可怕的事情
with all of the travel and all of the meeting. Yeah, it's a lot. Now, speaking of masks, I bet you really enjoy the anonymity of walking around with a mask and you can get away with it now because masks are so sort of ubiquitous, right? Yeah, so are you, have you taken like a big risk with a mask lately? Like have you done like the, like gone to Disneyland with a mask on? Yeah, or murder. Cause you could walk into a really, a really huge public place that you probably otherwise wouldn't
伴随着所有的旅行和所有的会议。是的，很多。现在，说到口罩，我敢说你真的很享受戴着口罩四处走动的匿名感，而且你现在可以逃脱惩罚，因为口罩太普遍了，对吧？是的，所以你，你最近戴口罩冒过大险吗？比如你有没有戴着口罩去过迪士尼乐园？是的，或者谋杀。因为你可以走进一个非常、非常巨大的公共场所，否则你可能
be able to get through. Wait, do you want to know my secret? I do it all the fucking time. I literally walk around for hours and hours and hours whenever I'm off. That was my next part of my schedule that I was going to tell you on my off day. I meander and I shop and I walk and I go and I go to the movie theater and I see movies and I wear like a little hood and a cap and I'm just like I have to be able to like otherwise I'll fall apart. I really love it. And then also, also like I really do enjoy meeting people.
无法通过。等等，你想知道我的秘密吗？我一直都在做。只要我休息，我就会走上几个小时。那是我要告诉你的我休息日日程的下一部分。我漫步，我购物，我走路，我去电影院看电影，我戴着小兜帽和帽子，我只是觉得我必须能够，否则我会崩溃。我真的很喜欢它。然后还有，还有，我也真的很喜欢见人。
So like, you know, it's fine. And I love it. Like it's like really nice. I met the cutest, the cutest waiter the other day. He was so sweet and he had a little tattoo, a little sweetener tattoo. It was like made my day. He was so sweet and he had a little tattoo, a little sweetener tattoo. It was like made my day. I love meeting people but I... So did you pull the mask down and go, hi? Oh, I didn't have a mask on that day. Oh, oh, oh.
所以，你知道，没关系。我喜欢它。就像这真的很好。我前几天遇到了最可爱的服务员。他太甜了，他有一个小纹身，一个小甜味剂纹身。这让我的一天都很美好。他太甜了，他有一个小纹身，一个小甜味剂纹身。这让我的一天都很美好。我喜欢见人，但我……所以你把口罩拉下来，说，嗨？哦，那天我没戴口罩。哦，哦，哦。
But no, he was just like, but I do love... But do you give people that treat like you're in a store and like they're helping you? You're like, oh, this person is cute. Pull the mask down, give them a little treat. Like, look who it is. And they're like, oh my God. Well, first of all, I don't always have a mask on. I just mean like if I'm like, look who it is, and they're like, oh my God! Well, first of all, I don't always have a mask on.
但是不，他只是像，但我确实喜欢……但你会给人们那种款待吗，比如你在商店里，他们正在帮助你？你就像，哦，这个人很可爱。把口罩拉下来，给他们一点款待。就像，看看是谁。他们就像，哦，天哪。好吧，首先，我并不总是戴着口罩。我只是说如果我像，看看是谁，他们就像，哦，天哪！好吧，首先，我并不总是戴着口罩。
I just mean like if I'm like, you know, meandering around Broadway. Yeah, yeah. It's the best, I'm here now, and I was walking around, I went and got coffee, and they asked me to put a mask on. Oh no. Yeah, yeah, they said, cover it. They didn't want to see you.
我只是说如果我像，你知道，在百老汇漫步。是的，是的。这是最好的，我现在在这里，我四处走动，我去买了咖啡，他们让我戴上口罩。哦，不。是的，是的，他们说，盖上它。他们不想看到你。
You're so silly. It's so true. All right, so then what's next on the dream board for acting? Wait, I never got to tell you my thing about the masks. Do it. This is like, when I said, this was the butt, I've always loved masks. I think they are so cute and I used to sell them
你太傻了。这是真的。好吧，那么演戏的梦想板上接下来是什么？等等，我还没告诉你关于口罩的事情。说吧。这就是，当我说是的时候，这是那个“但是”，我一直很喜欢口罩。我觉得它们太可爱了，我曾经卖过它们
as merch on my tour with a little moon on them because it was a cute thing that me and my fans always wore and it was a cute thing and it was a fans like always wore and it was like a cute thing and it was like a fashion thing, we liked it. And then when the pandemic happened, all of my fans were like, we are prepared. We have plenty of these. We have moon masks.
作为我巡演的周边，上面有一个小月亮，因为那是我和粉丝们一直戴的可爱东西，这是一个可爱的东西，粉丝们一直戴着它，就像一个可爱的东西，它就像一个时尚的东西，我们喜欢它。然后当大流行发生时，我所有的粉丝都说，我们准备好了。我们有很多这些。我们有月亮口罩。
Yes, thank you, sorry, that was what I was gonna say. Good, I love that. Next up is an acting thing or a music thing? What do you think? Or can you talk about it yet? I would love to continue acting. That is my, I feel so connected to it. I really would love to find the right thing
是的，谢谢，抱歉，那是我要说的。好，我喜欢那个。接下来是演戏还是音乐？你觉得呢？或者你现在能谈谈吗？我很想继续演戏。那是我的，我感觉和它联系太紧密了。我真的很想找到合适的事情
that challenges me in a new way. I love it so much. I think it's, I love it for different reasons than music. I mean, it's just so nice to kind of take a break from playing yourself. Like a caricaturized version of yourself that isn't really yourself, but it kind of is because parts of it are in the songs.
以一种新的方式挑战我。我太喜欢它了。我认为它是，我喜欢它是因为和音乐不同的原因。我的意思是，从扮演自己中休息一下真是太好了。就像一个不是真正的你，但又有点像你的漫画版自己，因为部分内容在歌曲里。
So it's just a confusing little thing. And I think what a like cool thing it is to find characters that you can kind of jump into. Right, which are other parts of yourself, the other reaches, yeah? Yeah, I suppose. I mean, you can heal little parts of yourself through them and with them and for them
所以这只是一个令人困惑的小事情。我认为找到你可以跳进去的角色是一件多么酷的事情。对，那是你自己的其他部分，其他的延伸，是吗？是的，我想是这样。我的意思是，你可以通过它们、和它们一起、为了它们治愈你自己的一小部分
that you didn't know needed to be looked at because when you're finding commonality. In comedy versus drama, do you lean one way or the other, do you think? I love both. I think Glinda had,, you know, Glinda had a, the biggest gift of Glinda is that there's a little bit of both, you know, especially with, you know, part two,
你不知道需要被审视的部分，因为当你找到共同点时。在喜剧和戏剧之间，你更倾向于哪一个，你觉得？我都喜欢。我认为格琳达有……你知道，格琳达有一个，格琳达最大的天赋是两者都有一点，你知道，特别是，你知道，第二部分，
you get to see more of her and get to know more of her, and she goes through a little bit more, but, you know, it's, the combination is really special. I think I love roles that have room for all of it. And that's what I love so much about her is that the comedy plays so well because it's just truth and underneath it is a very real person with very real insecurities
你可以看到更多关于她的东西，更多地了解她，她经历了一点点更多，但是，你知道，这是，这种结合真的很特别。我想我喜欢有空间容纳所有这些的角色。这就是我如此喜欢她的原因，喜剧效果很好，因为它是真相，而在它之下是一个有着非常真实的不安全感的人
and fears and things and it just gets to live there. So hopefully both, and if I'm lucky, both in one. You know? Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think it's, Sean, you've always, I have always thought that you should try comedy. Yeah, truly. Because you know what I mean?
和恐惧和事情，它只是在那里生活。所以希望两者都有，如果我幸运的话，两者合二为一。你知道吗？是的，是的，是的。我认为它是，肖恩，你一直，我一直认为你应该尝试喜剧。是的，真的。因为你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, give it a shot, buddy. Yeah, you should. I'm going to really, well, you know what? Thank you for the push. Thank you for the push. Yeah, you can take an improv class or something just to sort of see if it's for you. That would be a really good exercise for you, actually. Well, should we you know what? Thank you for the push. Thank you for the push. Yeah. I was thinking improv class or something, just to sort of see if it's for you.
是的，试一试，伙计。是的，你应该。我真的会，好吧，你知道吗？谢谢你的推动。谢谢你的推动。是的，你可以参加一个即兴表演班之类的，看看它是否适合你。那对你来说确实是一个很好的练习。好吧，我们应该，你知道吗？谢谢你的推动。谢谢你的推动。是的。我在想即兴表演班之类的，看看它是否适合你。
That would be a really good exercise for you, actually. Well, should we do one now? Give me a place. Let's do one now. Give me a place, and uh. Let's do one. Um, what about, what about, what about the, what about the music videos?
那对你来说确实是一个很好的练习。好吧，我们现在做一个吗？给我一个地方。我们现在做一个。给我一个地方，然后……我们做一个。嗯，关于，关于，关于，关于音乐录影带？
Sean just did it, and I'm sorry, go ahead. All right, Adam, do you love getting involved with the music videos and the whole design of them, and the concept of them them and the concept of them and the shooting of it and all that or? Yeah, I love the Yes and one. Oh my God, so good. Oh, thank you. I love that one. Thank you.
肖恩刚做了，抱歉，继续。好吧，亚当，你喜欢参与音乐录影带以及它们的整体设计，还有它们的概念，以及拍摄过程等等吗？是的，我喜欢《Yes and》那个。哦，天哪，太棒了。哦，谢谢。我喜欢那个。谢谢。
Yeah, I really feel like I found my like, my like lifelong music video collaborator in Christian Breslau, or who I just started working with for the Eternal Sunshine era. He did Yes and, he did We Can't Be Friends, he did The Boyz II, he did all of those things. And not that you have any idea what those are,
是的，我真的觉得我找到了我的，我的终身音乐录影带合作者克里斯蒂安·布雷斯劳尔，我刚开始为《永恒阳光》时代和他合作。他做了《Yes and》，他做了《We Can't Be Friends》，他做了《The Boyz II》，他做了所有这些事情。并不是说你知道那些是什么，
but I just plan on continuing with him forever when there's something to do. It will be with him, I love him. And I love it, it's so collaborative. We speak the same language, we love all the same references. Like we just kind of were destined to meet. You know when you meet like a creative person and you're like, where have you been my whole life?
但我只是打算永远和他一起继续下去，当有事情要做时。那将和他一起，我爱他。我喜欢它，它太具有协作性了。我们说同样的语言，我们喜欢所有相同的参考资料。就像我们注定要相遇一样。你知道当你遇到一个有创造力的人，你会说，你这辈子都在哪里？
And it's just kind of this cosmic collision. But like, so when you're in the recording studio and let's say you're not in the recording area, whatever that's called, but you're back where the board is with all the slidey things on it. Do you love sitting there and playing with those buttons? The slidey things. I'm dying. Or do you like being on a movie set and talking about lenses or the acting stuff, the shiny stuff? Do you like both of those workplaces evenly?
这只是一种宇宙碰撞。但是，所以当你在录音室里，假设你不在录音区，无论那叫什么，但你在后面有所有滑动按钮的控制台那里。你喜欢坐在那里玩那些按钮吗？滑动的东西。我要死了。或者你喜欢在电影片场谈论镜头或表演的东西，那些闪亮的东西？你喜欢这两个工作场所吗？
Holy fuck. Yes, I mean, well, I have different relationships to them both, because I feel like with acting I love to just kind of be the character and go away. Like I don't want to know what the playback looks like. I don't want to know or be aware of what my face is doing or my body is doing, I just want it to happen and then hopefully it'll make sense later. Which is a huge risk, I realize I'm saying that,
该死。是的，我的意思是，嗯，我对它们都有不同的关系，因为我觉得演戏时我喜欢只是成为角色然后消失。就像我不想知道回放看起来是什么样。我不想知道或意识到我的脸在做什么或我的身体在做什么，我只是想让它发生，然后希望以后会有意义。我意识到我这么说是一个巨大的风险，
but also I just don't want to be aware of it because I just want to be honest and then if I'm judging what I look like or whatever, I won't have the ability to just be a character. And that's my own thing in my head. But with vocal producing, I'm like, it's my own thing in my head. But with vocal producing, I'm like, it's my favorite thing in the world. So yes, the slidey thingies, of course.
但我只是不想意识到它，因为我只想诚实，然后如果我评判我的样子或无论什么，我就没有能力只是成为一个角色。这是我脑子里的事情。但对于声乐制作，我像，这是我脑子里的事情。但对于声乐制作，我像，这是我世界上最喜欢的事情。所以是的，滑动的东西，当然。
It's my number one favorite thing to do, even more so than singing, is vocal production and comping vocals and staffing and vocal arranging. I'm like a huge nerd in that way. So what about taking on a young performer and producing that performer and making he or she, you know, really sore? Love being able to vocal produce. Literally like that is just a dream.
这是我最喜欢做的事情，甚至比唱歌还多，就是声乐制作和合成人声以及编排。我在那方面是个大书呆子。那么收一个年轻的表演者并制作那个表演者，让他或她，你知道，真正腾飞呢？喜欢能够进行声乐制作。字面上就像那只是一个梦想。
Like if someone calls me and is like, I want you to record me. I absolutely have done it, will do it, love it, will take that call any day. I got to actually, wait, I have a fun story. I got to vocal produce some of the Wicked soundtrack. I got to vocal produce Cynthia and some of my stuff too. So that was really cool and such a treat. And to anyone who questions the live element of the vocals in Defying Gravity in that second verse
就像如果有人打电话给我说，我想让你录我。我绝对做过，也会做，喜欢它，随时会接那个电话。我其实，等等，我有一个有趣的故事。我负责了《魔法坏女巫》原声带的部分声乐制作。我负责了辛西娅和我自己的一些东西的声乐制作。所以那真的很酷，也是一种享受。对于任何质疑《Defying Gravity》第二段中现场人声元素的人，
when she's going up the stairs in Defying Gravity, if you solo that vocal, you can hear her little boots on the stairs. And yeah. Oh wow, that's amazing. Yeah, it's so cool that you guys sing it live. It's crazy. Yeah, Heaven on Earth is being able to sift through
当她在《Defying Gravity》中走上楼梯时，如果你单独播放那个人声，你可以听到她靴子在楼梯上的声音。是的。哦，哇，那太神奇了。是的，你们现场演唱真是太疯狂了。是的，人间天堂就是能够筛选
a bunch of Cynthia Arrivo vocal takes. You know what I mean? Because it's not about finding the good one. It's about finding which perfect, amazing one is the choice that you. Did you hear that thing that was going around for a while that on New Year's Eve, if you started watching the movie at a certain time, by midnight, you would hit the whoa!
一堆辛西娅·艾莉佛的人声录音。你知道我的意思吗？因为这不是关于找到好的那个。这是关于找到哪个完美、惊人的那个是你选择的。你听过那个流传了一段时间的事情吗，在除夕夜，如果你在某个时间开始看电影，到午夜，你就会听到“哇！”
Yes, I saw several videos of that. Yeah. I read that well, right, on the website? I saw that too. Yeah, came up on your feed. I was about to, and Sean cut me off and took my fucking, remember what the New Year is,
是的，我看了几个那样的视频。是的，我在网站上读到那个，对吧？我也看到了。是的，出现在你的动态里。我正要，肖恩打断了我，拿走了我该死的，记得新年是什么，
and I was like, write it, he was like, whoa! And I was like, fuck yeah. Why'd you miss it? Why'd you miss out? You missed out, you missed out. No! Wait, so Arianna, I don't know why I'm remembering this, but one of the cutest, greatest things you ever did,
我当时说，写下来，他就像，哇！我当时说，该死，是的。你为什么错过了？你为什么错过了？你错过了，你错过了。不！等等，所以爱莉安娜，我不知道为什么我记得这个，但你做过的最可爱、最伟大的事情之一，
this is 10 years ago, around 10 years ago, we were doing Hairspray Live, we were sitting there in the makeup trailer, and you said to me, and you said, just a little off the top. Just a little off the top. Just tease up the top a little bit more. I'm so scared.
这是 10 年前，大约 10 年前，我们正在做《发胶星梦》直播，我们坐在化妆车里，你对我说，你说，只要把上面剪掉一点点。只要把上面剪掉一点点。只要把上面再稍微弄蓬松一点。我太害怕了。
No, no, you turned to me and you said, hey, there's just a few of us going over to my house after later on tonight, we're going to get totally wasted and sleep over, wait, and then sleep over and in the morning my mom's going to make us pancakes. And I- Did I say that? Yes, and that was so sweet, you invited me
不，不，你转向我说，嘿，今天晚上晚些时候只有我们几个人去我家，我们要喝得烂醉然后过夜，等等，然后过夜，早上我妈妈会给我们做煎饼。我……我说了吗？是的，那太甜了，你邀请了我
and I turned to you and I go, Ariana? You said, yeah, I go, I'm 45 years old. That is absolutely crazy. That is so sweet though, it was so sweet. You said, I'm 45 years old, I'll see you for the pancakes. Oh yes. I can't believe that that's how I would have ever said anything ever. And I actually do remember that cast party. That was like so funny.
我转向你说，爱莉安娜？你说，是的，我说，我 45 岁了。那绝对太疯狂了。但这太甜了，真的太甜了。你说，我 45 岁了，我会去吃煎饼的。哦，是的。我不敢相信我竟然会那样说任何话。我确实记得那个杀青派对。那真是太搞笑了。
And I remember like, yeah. Can you believe that was almost 10 years ago? Isn't that wild? It was a long time ago. And I just wanted to bring up that your boyfriend is a very good friend of mine. Yes, he loves you so much. I love him too, Ethan Slater. He's one of the nicest people you'll ever meet in your life. He did Good Night Oscar with me in Chicago.
我记得，是啊。你能相信那已经是快10年前的事了吗？是不是很疯狂？那是很久以前的事了。我只是想提一下，你的男朋友是我非常好的朋友。是的，他非常爱你。我也很爱他，伊森·斯莱特。他是我这辈子见过最善良的人之一。他在芝加哥和我一起演过《晚安，奥斯卡》。
And then he was in Wicked. And now you guys are dating and I love that because you guys make a perfect couple. Thank you, he's amazing and he loves you. What part did he play? He was the PA guy with the, you know. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. But Ariana, next time you're on or whenever, I want to hear a horrible theater story gone wrong
后来他演了《魔法坏女巫》。现在你们在交往，我很高兴，因为你们是天造地设的一对。谢谢，他很棒，他也爱你。他演什么角色？他演那个制片助理，就是那个，你知道的。哦，对对对。但是爱莉安娜，下次你来或者什么时候，我想听一个糟糕的戏剧故事，就是那种搞砸了的故事。
in 13 or some other theater show because of my favorite stories. I have a thousand of them. I have some. Yeah, tell me one. We've got time for one. We got two. Then we're going to let you go.
在《13》或者其他戏剧演出中，因为我最喜欢听这种故事了。我有一千个这样的故事。我有一些。好，讲一个给我听。我们还有时间讲一个。我们有两个。然后我们就放你走。
No, that's totally fine. I realize you all probably have like a heart out of like right now. Yeah, tell me one. We've got time for one. We've got two. Then we're going to let you go. Yeah. No, that's totally fine. I realize you all probably have like a heart out of like right now. No, no, no. You do. I want to hear it. I feel like I'm having tea with the dames and I'm in heaven. No, no, no.
不，完全没问题。我知道你们可能现在就得走了。是啊，讲一个给我听。我们还有时间讲一个。我们有两个。然后我们就放你走。是啊。不，完全没问题。我知道你们可能现在就得走了。不不不。你得讲。我觉得我像是在和名媛们喝下午茶，我简直在天堂。不不不。
It's yours. So I was, so my best friend, Aaron Simon Gross, who I actually grew up in Boca with and he and I auditioned for 13 on the same day together and we both got cast, which just like never happens crazy. He was playing Archie, which was the character in the show, and he has these spontaneous nosebleeds that are just really flocking. Oh cool. Yeah, but it's the kind from a scary movie.
那是你的故事。当时，我最好的朋友亚伦·西蒙·格罗斯，我和他一起在博卡长大，我们俩在同一天为《13》试镜，结果我们俩都被选上了，这简直是从未发生过的事，太疯狂了。他演阿奇，就是剧里的那个角色，他会自发性流鼻血，而且流得非常凶。哦，酷。是啊，就像恐怖电影里的那种。
It's not good. The guys are, oh wow. Yeah, it's really, it's aggressive. And it's not the kind of thing that is like. Aggressive nosebleeds. Yeah, you know when you see something and it takes you out of body for a second. Because you're not supposed to be happening at all.
那可不好。伙计们，哦哇。是啊，真的很猛。而且那不是那种……猛烈的鼻血。是啊，你知道当你看到某种东西，让你瞬间出窍的感觉吗？因为那根本就不该发生。
So he's in the wings waiting for his entrance and we used to have this cute moment in the opening number where I was on stage and I'd be like, I would sing one of the lines into the wings waiting for his entrance. and I see him covered in blood. Just covered in blood. And I was like, oh my God. And he had to enter and get through his entire first scene. Was he aware that he was bleeding?
所以他在侧台等着上场，我们以前在开场曲里有一个可爱的瞬间，当时我在台上，我会唱其中一句歌词，等着他上场。然后我看到他满脸是血。满脸都是血。我当时想，天哪。他必须上场并演完他的整场戏。他意识到自己在流血吗？
Yeah, he was looking at me like he was, had no idea what to do and also his character, he was using crutches in the role and he couldn't wipe himself. What, did the audience gasp? Yeah, they were like, huh! And then when they realized it wasn't a part of the plot at all, that this just like blood covered man was entering and then he was singing,
是的，他看着我，好像完全不知道该怎么办，而且他的角色在戏里要拄拐杖，他没法擦自己。什么，观众惊呼了吗？是的，他们当时发出“啊！”的声音。然后当他们意识到这根本不是剧情的一部分，这个满脸是血的男人走上台，然后他还在唱歌，
and he's like singing and he's like, there's the cool kids, there's... And he's like singing his first number, spitting blood onto Graham Phillips, who was playing the lead role. It was just like the craziest thing and it never ended. Did you try to help him out? There was nothing to, how? Yeah, yeah. Just keep your distance, right? I had to exit.
他一边唱歌一边说，那是酷小孩，那是……他唱着他的第一首歌，把血喷到了演主角的格雷厄姆·菲利普斯身上。那简直是最疯狂的事情，而且根本停不下来。你试着帮他了吗？根本没法帮，怎么帮？是啊，是啊。只能保持距离，对吧？我不得不退场。
One time I was at the end of promises, promises, thank you. I would. We usually, no we'll create space and put the applause in there. We were coming out, me and Kristin Chenoweth were coming out for our bows, and we would do the same thing, we'd be in the wings from opposite sides of the stage
有一次我在演《承诺，承诺》的结尾，谢谢。我会的。我们通常，不，我们会留出空间，把掌声放进去。我们当时正出来谢幕，我和克里斯汀·肯诺恩斯正出来谢幕，我们会做同样的事，我们会在舞台两侧的侧台，
and lock eyes before we'd come out and meet at the middle to come downstage for our bow. And one night, the audience is clapping, everybody's taking their bows, and where I'm supposed to see her, she's on the ground, passed out with her feet under the curtain like the wickedicked Witch of the West. Not on the house.
在出来之前对视一眼，然后在中间汇合，走到台前谢幕。有一天晚上，观众在鼓掌，大家都在谢幕，我本该看到她的地方，她却倒在地上，脚还在幕布下面，就像《绿野仙踪》里的西方坏女巫。不是在房子上。
Yes, and I was like, oh my God, so I took my bow by myself. People were like, what happened to, the audience was like, where's, she did, she fainted. No way. Oh no. You know what the thing is? This just reminded me, this is true story. On Sunday, I was shooting this thing in California
是的，我当时想，天哪，所以我自己谢幕了。人们都在问，她怎么了，观众都在问，她在哪里，她晕倒了。不会吧。哦，不。你知道吗？这让我想起了一件事，这是真事。周日，我在加州拍戏，
and we were at lunch and there were a bunch of us sitting around in the trailer and this girl works in costumes, all of a sudden comes out of the bathroom and she's going like, like waving her finger and Eli goes, you can't talk. She goes, and she goes back and I go, you can't breathe. And she goes, oh, and I've never done it before. And I jumped up, I put my arms around her and I had three times and she barfed on my hands and she got it out I put my arms around her, and I had three times and she barfed on my hands, and she got it out.
我们在吃午饭，我们一群人坐在拖车里，那个负责服装的女孩突然从洗手间出来，她在那儿挥着手指，伊莱说，你不能说话。她走过来，我说，你不能呼吸。她说，哦，我以前从没做过。我跳起来，抱住她，我做了三次，她吐在我的手上，她把东西吐出来了。我抱住她，我做了三次，她吐在我的手上，她把东西吐出来了。
I've never done it before, but I was like, I think this is what you do. If you see something choking. Did you have to do it aggressively? Or did you have to like, yeah, because you gotta get it out of there. Well I guess we can't count on Eli. He just was like, oh, and he just hit it.
我以前从没做过，但我当时想，我想这就是你该做的。如果你看到有人窒息。你必须用力做吗？还是你必须……是啊，因为你得把它弄出来。好吧，我想我们不能指望伊莱。他只是说，哦，然后他就撞了一下。
Well he, and then when I grabbed her, he ran out to get the paramedic, and the paramedic came in and she was like, I'm fine now, and I'm like covered in, threw up. I'm like, she's fine now. She was choking. She was choking, yeah. Oh my God, Will, that's, that's scary.
好吧，他，然后当我抓住她时，他跑出去找医护人员，医护人员进来，她说，我现在没事了，我身上全是呕吐物。我说，她现在没事了。她刚才窒息了。她刚才窒息了，是啊。天哪，威尔，那太可怕了。
It was pretty wild. I've never, I don't even know if I was really doing it right. It worked, but I didn't know what I was doing, and I thought like, oh shit, I should learn how to do a proper handstand. Yeah, you need to learn that and CPR. Yeah, and CPR. That's really, that's really scary.
那真的很疯狂。我从来没，我甚至不知道我做得对不对。它奏效了，但我不知道我在做什么，我想，哦该死，我应该学学怎么做正规的海姆立克急救法。是啊，你需要学那个和心肺复苏术。是啊，还有心肺复苏术。那真的很可怕。
And I've been asking people on the street here if they want to do a proper handstand and CPR. Yeah, and CPR. That's really scary. And I've been asking people on the street here if they wanna do, practice CPR. And all these dudes are like, no, and whatever. But anyway. Can I get your number? I'll try later. I'll let you try later. Let me come over here, man.
我一直在问街上的人，他们想不想学正规的海姆立克急救法和心肺复苏术。是啊，还有心肺复苏术。那真的很可怕。我一直在问街上的人，他们想不想练习心肺复苏术。所有这些家伙都说，不，什么的。但不管怎样。我能要你的号码吗？我稍后再试。我让你稍后再试。让我过来这边，伙计。
It's time, it's time. But isn't that crazy? That is. Yeah, that's a lot. I didn't include that in coffee chat at the top of the episode. I forgot about it until we were just talking about crazy things and I was like,
是时候了，是时候了。但这不疯狂吗？确实。是啊，这太夸张了。我没在节目开头的咖啡聊天里提到这个。我忘了，直到我们刚才谈到疯狂的事情，我才想起来，
oh yeah, this just happened three days ago. Well on that note, Arianna, we hope you don't choke. Thanks for being here. Thank you, holy fuck, thank you so much for having me. I hope I don't ever have to save your life, I guess is my point. Oh my goodness. We'll see you in six months in London.
哦对，这事三天前才发生。好吧，说到这，爱莉安娜，我们希望你别窒息。谢谢你来到这里。谢谢，天哪，非常感谢你们邀请我。我想说的是，我希望我永远不必救你的命。哦，天哪。六个月后伦敦见。
Yes. Continued great luck, You're the best. Thank you for having me. Thank you for saying yes to this. Enjoy the rest of your day. Continued success. Love you all, thank you. And love the Ethan too, please.
好的。祝你继续好运，你是最棒的。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢你答应来参加。祝你余下的一天愉快。祝你继续成功。爱你们所有人，谢谢。也请代我向伊森问好。
I will, love you guys, bye. Thank you so much. Bye, bye, bye. That was Ariana Grande, the Ariana Grande. A pure delight. She's great. She's so funny, man. That's what I said, people don't know how funny she is.
我会的，爱你们，再见。非常感谢。再见，再见，再见。那是爱莉安娜·格兰德，就是那个爱莉安娜·格兰德。纯粹的快乐。她很棒。她太搞笑了，伙计。我就是这么说的，人们不知道她有多搞笑。
Yeah, she's funny. I mean, they do now, because Glinda was really funny. I can't wait for people to discover how funny you are. If you take that intro off class and you get yourself an agent, I bet you get a guest spot or two or three, and then people are gonna say, hey. Well, at the very least, I think you'll get an agent.
是啊，她很搞笑。我是说，他们现在知道了，因为格琳达真的很搞笑。我迫不及待想让人们发现你有多搞笑。如果你把那个介绍去掉，给自己找个经纪人，我敢打赌你会得到一两个或三个客串机会，然后人们会说，嘿。好吧，至少我觉得你会找到经纪人的。
Yeah, hey guys, did you ever get this when you were younger? Can you hook me up with your agent? Right. Can you get me? Yeah. No. But yeah, I would love to see her do tons more acting. Yeah.
是啊，嘿伙计们，你们年轻时有没有遇到过这种情况？你能帮我联系你的经纪人吗？对。你能帮我吗？是啊。不。但确实，我很想看到她做更多表演。是啊。
I think that's what's gonna happen. I think she's gonna do a straight acting gig will be next. Yeah, for sure. Is my prediction. Yep, yep, and she's gonna kill it. And she's just starting, right? She's 30, 31, something like that. Yeah, kind of amazing.
我想这就是会发生的事。我想她接下来的工作会是纯表演。是啊，肯定的。这是我的预测。没错，没错，她会大获成功的。她才刚开始，对吧？她30岁，31岁，差不多那样。是啊，真是太神奇了。
With all of that success already. But has a great head on her shoulders clearly and seems well suited for all that's a coming. Yeah, and you know what a great musical that she- Oh, hang on a second, Sean. Oh, hang on, Sean. Sean, do you want to cut in with something because you're ready to get on it
已经取得了这么多成就。但她显然很有头脑，而且似乎很适合未来的一切。是啊，你知道她演的那部伟大的音乐剧……哦，等一下，肖恩。哦，等一下，肖恩。肖恩，你想插话吗，因为你准备好要开始了，
and to get on the bike? He's got a great one. I just thought maybe like a... Have you ever heard the expression, like smell the roses or just fucking just exist and not act out in the moment to get stuff done as quickly as possible? I thought that you were setting up a bike. Yeah, shut the hell up, Will. No, I thought that you were saying if I get a bye. I thought I was gonna do a bye.
要开始骑车了吗？他有一个很棒的。我只是觉得也许……你有没有听过那种表达，比如闻闻玫瑰花香，或者只是他妈的活在当下，不要为了尽快完成事情而表现得那么急躁？我以为你在准备自行车。是啊，闭嘴吧，威尔。不，我以为你在说如果我得到一个再见（bye）。我以为我要做一个再见。
Yeah, yeah, shut the hell up, Will. No, I'm teaching you a lesson. Shut, thank you. Shut, shut up. You say shut up, Will. What do you got? I was gonna say what? Here it comes.
是啊，是啊，闭嘴吧，威尔。不，我在给你上一课。闭，谢谢。闭，闭嘴。你说闭嘴，威尔。你有什么要说的？我本来想说，什么？来了。
A musical that I'd really like to see her in. Bye Bye, Birdie. Yes, you motherfucker! Sorry, I meant to say bye bye, Birdie! Bye, bye, Birdie! Bye! There's something about your face, and hopefully to say, bye, bye, Bernie. Bye. There's something about your face, and hopefully we're still recording, there's something about your face when you go,
一部我真的很想看她演的音乐剧。《再见，伯迪》。是的，你这个混蛋！抱歉，我是想说《再见，伯迪》！《再见，伯迪》！再见！你的脸有些表情，希望我们还在录音，当你做那个表情时，你的脸有些表情，
yeah, and I'm like, OK, here we go. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
是啊，我当时想，好吧，我们开始吧。Smart。Less。SmartLess是100%有机且手工制作的Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Less。Smart。Less。Smart。Less。Smart。本集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。